- Like my family to this
day still call me Gig.
So I'm completely comfortable
with just people calling
me Gigguk or Garnt.
- If my parents call me Anime Man.
(laughing)
I would think I was like
disowned or something.
(both laughs)
- If they call me the Anime
Zone on the other hand,
then now we got a problem.
(upbeat soft music)
- What's up you eccentric
ecchi enthusiasts?
Welcome back to another episode
of the Trash Taste podcast.
- Absolutely terrible.
- Pretty awful.
- I'm so sorry.
I'm so sorry.
- Look, it's gonna be a thing from now on.
Okay, you guys have to just brace yourself
every three episodes.
'Cause I'm always gonna open
with something like that.
Okay.
Meilyne, our producer, stop making noise.
(both laughs)
Jesus Christ.
- This is a professional production.
- You've ruined my intro.
Goddamn it.
- Excuse me Meilyne,
I thought we-
we have professionalism on this.
- Trash production on
this Trash Taste Podcast.
- I know right?
- Jesus Christ.
Well, welcome to another episode
of Trash Taste where we
talk about Trash Tastes
in Anime and everything else in the world.
I'm your host, Joey.
- Wait, is that an intro now?
- Yeah, I guess.
- My God, that was like,
that went from 'What the
fuck are you saying?'
to 'Man this is a smooth ass intro'.
We didn't agree on any of this.
- I'm a professional after all.
I'm your host for today Joey,
and as always, joining me
are the boys, Garnt and Connor.
- Hey guys.
- No nickname, I don't know.
- Okay.
Okay, okay
I'm the Hentai Kid and
this is GiggUK Arizona.
And the 93%
- All right
- You guys are on the subreddit
have just been going crazy
with those memes, right now.
- I mean, we don't pick them nicknames.
They pick the nicknames
at the end of the day.
Right?
- Exactly, exactly.
So, yeah guys,
what are we going to talk about today?
Oh, wait.
You were thinking about
something, all right?
- I watched-
- That you wanted to talk about
You were thinking something
spicy to talk about.
- Yeah, you talk about YouTube
but I think before we do that,
I watched "Perfect Blue" recently.
- Oh!
(group clapping)
- You broke your Satoshi Kon virginity.
- I'm proud of you, I'm proud of you.
- Unlike Garnt, right?
Where if we bring up a show,
you're like "Yeah, you should watch it."
Garnt's gonna be like, "Whoof."
You know what I mean?
Like-
- I actually started
watching "Dorohedoro",
- You actually did?
- Yeah.
- Everyone is breaking their cherries.
- I just thought because of
the Full Metal Alchemist curse.
- They're no gonna to know that
because that was on the episode
where we recorded an episode
and then the audio just
wasn't recording apparently.
- Yeah, it's the lost
episode you'll not get to see
- I did like a 10 minute speech on
why Dorohedoro was good
and you should watch it.
- Yeah.
But no, yeah.
Perfect Blue, yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
How did you find it?
- It was amazing.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- I knew it was going to be good, right?
Everything I've seen of it
and the amount of works that its inspired.
It's obvious it was going to be good.
- Yeah.
- But yeah,
I was kinda not ready for
what I was going to watch
(Joey chuckles)
- No one is when they're
going to watch it.
- Like it was a lot,
some of the scenes are pretty whoof.
- Yeah.
Like how would you feel watching it today?
Because this came out in,
I think 1995 or something like that.
Which 1995? 1997?
It came out in the nineties
- It's at least 20 years old.
- Yeah.
- How'd you feel it is now watching it
for the first time in today's climate?
- It's really creepy being
like an online personality
watching a story about-
- [Joey] Right.
- Yeah.
- Another online personality
- And that's, what's
scary about it, right.
Is that the themes in that
are just as prevalent today,
as it was back then.
- [Garnt And Connor] Yeah.
- If not worse I feel
- No no, I feel like
it's more relevant today.
Over 20 years later than
it was when it came out.
Do you wanna explain
quickly what the story is?
Cause it's been a while
since I've watched it.
- Oh my God, I mean that's hard.
(both laughs)
It's a mindfuck, it's horror
but it's essentially there's
this girl who is an idol.
She then quits becoming
an idol to pursue a career
in film acting.
But then, that's all sort of
like a side plot, I guess.
But there's a guy who
was obsessed with her.
And the whole point of the story is
that he is obsessed with
the image of the celebrity
not the actual personality
of the celebrity.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- And then it's kind of
a story about how much
as an online personality or a celebrity,
how much of your public persona do you own
and how much of that do
you have control over.
- Yeah.
Is it actually you, who is the real you?
Is it who you perceive yourself as online?
Or is it who you are as a person?
And the fact that this came out
in the nineties, where-
- It's way away ahead of its time.
- Like what the fuck right?
It predicted so much about how
social media would work
and our perceptions
of like online celebrities,
and how people are viewed online.
And-
- It's just like Satoshi
Kon's cinematography
is just so out of this world.
I love that scene,
the one scene I vividly remember
is like when the stalker guy is
at the main character's concert.
- Yeah.
- And he just hold his hand up.
- Oh, that was such a good shot.
- That is just so, so good
because it's just such good imagery.
- Yeah
- Right.
- He was ugly as fuck.
- Oh yeah
- He looked like a human beetle.
(both laughing)
I was like, "Oh, so he's the bad guy."
- This boy was the OG ugly bastard.
- [Garnt And Connor] Yeah
(Garnt laughing)
- Every ugly bastard
was based off that guy.
- No kidding.
It's amazing.
Like it was, I feel like
it's, again, like you said
it's so relevant at this time.
And I think anyone can-
I think it's more relevant now
than it wasn't when it come out.
- And the way he pulled it off as well
because it wasn't just a simple story.
It was weaved in with just
pure top-class filmmaking.
Like, there was a point
when you don't notice the transition
but it transitions into,
"Okay, what's real?
What's like her imagination?
What's part of the film?"
Because one of the genius
parts of this story
is that because she's
like an actress as well-
- They use of the world of the acting.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- They use the world
of the acting and like the filmmaking
to blend into her real life.
So you don't know which scenes
are like really happening
and which scenes are just being acted.
And its, it fucks with your mind.
- Yeah, 'cause like there's
three worlds, right?
'Cause there's the real world,
the acting world
and then the stuff
that she's seeing in her head.
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah.
- And it's so hard trying
to like unwind all that.
And trying to figure out what's what.
But then I guess,
almost a certain extent,
you're not supposed to.
- Yeah, yeah.
You're supposed to be confused.
- Yeah, it's the fact that it's so blurry,
is what's showing you
why this whole thing is so scary.
Because you don't even
know watching what is real
and what is not real.
And I feel a lot of that,
kind of like, theming
in Satoshi Kon's movies
really transitioned over
to his latest stuff.
Did you ever watch "Paprika"?
- I haven't
- Yeah, I did, I did.
- Because Paprika,
I mean, for those of you who don't know
it's literally-
- [Connor] My favorite spice.
- [Joey] Anime inception.
- I mean, it's totally different
because it's like inception
is like a heist movie in a dream.
Satoshi.
Paprika is on a base level.
Yeah, they're both about dreams,
but Paprika is like 10
times more imaginative
in how he approaches its visuals,
when, in like, they're in
the dream world, right.
- And how he shows the dream world
versus the real world is very
much like in Perfect Blue.
Where you don't realize,
"Oh, we're in a dream world now."
Or, "Oh, we're back to reality."
And he does that
so seamlessly through the scenes.
It's really incredible.
- I think Perfect Blue is my
favorite Satoshi Kon movie.
A close second is Millennium Actress.
- [Joey] Millennium Actress, yeah.
- I saw a lot of people
said that he was his best work.
- Yeah.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Because I think he
took a lot of elements
from Perfect Blue in terms of,
so Millennium Actress, isn't a mind fuck.
But it basically tells
the story of this girl
through film basically.
So they, I think, she was-
The name's Millennium Actress.
She's an actress.
- She's an Actress.
- I was like, was she an actress?
I'm just like, wait a
minute, of course she was.
Damn.
- Millennium farmer.
(both laughs)
She was a farmer.
- Yeah.
But they show this
woman's whole life story,
just through various films that she shot
or maybe she didn't shoot them.
But it's just such, again,
it's such a seamless transition between
real life or the 'Canon'
real life of the movie
and a movie in a movie.
If that makes sense.
- It's good.
'Cause I mean, I also feel like
because of the position we're in,
it was like a weird, uncomfortable.
- It was Uncanny Valley, right?
- Some parts were a little bit too close.
- Yeah.
- [Joey] Yeah
- Just like, cause obviously
there's the personality
that we show in our videos, right?
And then it's our own personality.
Like, I don't have to
deal with it too much,
'cause I feel like I'm pretty close
to what I am in real life.
- I think all three of us are.
- [Garnt And Connor] Yeah.
- But I definitely have some friends
who are YouTubers
who are very, very different
to how they're perceived
I'm sure Emily won't mind me saying.
Emirichu, she's like a
story time animator, right?
Very like this image of
like pure, right, liken.
(Garnt and Joey laugh)
Everyone thinks that she's
like a Disney character.
- Right.
- But like you hang out with her,
she's a normal person, right.
- I mean, if you follow her on Twitter,
you will see it.
- Right.
- Right
And this is the thing right is that
I know she gets stressed
out with it more than most.
And she's told me a few
times that she's like
"I wish you would just stop treating me
like a Disney character."
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
Like people won't let us say things.
Cause when she says
things like, oh you know,
that are a little crude maybe.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- She gets a lot of comments being like
this is not how you're supposed to act.
- That's not you.
- Yeah, people literally tell her,
"You shouldn't act this way.
This is not how you're supposed to act."
And it's weird 'cause it's like,
I don't have to deal with that.
If I do whatever the fuck I want
and people like ha ha
funny, you know, teehee.
But like it's really creepy seeing people-
- It was weird for me-
- Force these things onto her
- Yeah, it was really weird for me
because I met Emily IRL
before I saw any of her YouTube stuff.
So, it was-
Me watching her videos, it was kind of
a reverse shock for me.
- [Garnt And Connor] Yeah
- I was like, wow, you're so pure
- Not to say that Emily
is like crazy or anything.
She's just a normal person.
- No no
- No
- I haven't met her personally but
- People are more dimensional
than a Disney persona.
- Yeah, yeah exactly.
- She doesn't even try
and put that on herself, right.
That's just because you know
- That's just get how
the audience perceive it.
It's funny because Sydney or sydsnap,
She has like the opposite problem where
people come to me and they're like,
"Why Sydney acting so hyperactive
and so loud in her videos?"
I'm like, the big difference
between Sydney in a videos
and Sydney in real life
is that Sydney in her
videos has a volume button.
(all laugh)
- It's true.
- I can physically turn her
down when she's in a video.
I can't physically turn
it down in real life.
- You can put like a normalization.
(Joey and Garnt laugh)
Can't do that in real life.
That shit peaks.
- You can't put a limit
on her voice, yeah.
(laughing)
- Yeah, and it's just, it
was really uncomfortable.
Like I said, it's uncomfortable at times.
It's really like unnerving.
And again, if take away anything from this
you should watch Perfect Blue.
- Yeah
- If you consume any
form of online content.
- Did you watch Requiem For A Dream?
- No, no I haven't
- Or Black Swan?
- Black Swan?
- I saw a bit of Black Swan.
I got really bored and I turned off.
- Yeah, a lot of,
I mean, both of those movies are
heavily, heavily influenced.
- Yeah, yeah, I show that Black
Swan was heavily inspired.
- It's funny that you fell
asleep during that one.
Because Black Swan is
basically the same storyline
- [Connor] I think I was
in a plane and you know,
sometimes you're in a mood,
where you're like,
"I don't wanna watch a movie,
but what else can I do?"
- Yeah
- I'm thinking I put Black Swan on.
I was like, it was not
the right environment
to watch Black Swan.
(Joey and Garnt laugh)
- Very dark room.
- 10 inch LCD, eating
those shitty pack nuts.
- I have this genre I like to call
'Plane Movies',
where it's like movies
you would never ever watch,
but when you're in a plane,
you're like "Eh".
- Every Jason Statham movie.
- Yeah I know
- [Joey] Yeah, exactly.
Every Mission Impossible.
- I'm pretty sure
his career and the Rock's career
are solely being funded by planes.
Like no one.
Why else would you watch
that fucking shark movie
that Jason Statham was in?
- Which shark movie?
- The whole movie was
him fighting a shark.
- What?
- What's the movie called?
- Are you serious?
Is this a movie?
- It's on the screen right now.
- Sharknado 4.
- It's just a movie
and I can't describe any of it to you.
It's just, the whole thing
was just this really-
- Jason Statham versus the shark.
- It's like imagine Jaws on steroids
and that was like the whole movie.
It was so bad.
- Oh, was it called like Megalodon?
- That was like mega-something?
Megachad?
(group laughs)
- Megachad
- Jason Statham is Megachad.
(Connor laughing)
- Yeah.
There's just too much fucking, oh my god.
So many movies, but yeah.
Jason Statham movie.
- Yeah, no, I agree with
the airplane movies thing.
I've, I've seen more movies on planes
than I think I have in, like,
cinemas and my own room.
- Yeah, I feel bad for anything
I watch on a plane.
Cause I feel like it automatically
loses two points out of 10.
(Garnt laughs)
Just because I watched it on the plane.
- No no, I know what you mean.
- Like I never have a positive memory
of binge-watching a series.
- But, sometimes I just
wanna fucking watch
some shitty thing.
Like, have you ever had
like before a plane,
like you download something
you actually wanna watch,
like an anime or a series of manga.
And then you're like,
"Ah, I don't really feel like watching.
Let me watch this shitty
five out of 10 show that's,
or movie that I would never watch
under any other circumstances.
- Mine is worse because I
go on a plane being like,
"Okay, I can work on a script
because I have my laptop."
- Do you work on a plane?
- No
- Okay
(Joey chuckles)
- I plan to every single time.
I'm like, "Okay, I'm gonna
like work on a script
or I'm going to play this game.
I'm going to finish it while I'm
on this 10 hour flight to the US.
But instead, now I'm going
to watch this really crap
documentary about this topic
that I just do not care about."
But because you're forced to watch it
by the end of it I'm just like,
"That was very informative."
(Garnt laughs)
I learnt a lot,
I'm glad I watched that.
- People who can like work on planes,
I don't know how they do it.
- I can do it on domestic flights.
- Oh, I can't, it's a,
you're a fucking madman
if you can work on planes.
- I think you have to be a sociopath.
- I'm sorry.
I guess I'm a sociopath.
(both laughs)
- I think so, I think so.
- It's weird, right?
Because, with airplane
movies, as you said-
- Yeah
- It's always like two points lower than
if you would watch it in a cinema.
- Cause it's not a comfortable
viewing experience-
- No, it's not.
- Which is all the more reason
why I wanna re-watch Maquia.
Because I watched Maquia on a flight.
- What the fuck is Maquia?
- You never heard of Maquia?
- I would never watch an anime film
that I want to watch on a flight.
I remember hearing people
watching Your Name
when it was like out in theaters
and the only chance they had to watch it,
was on the flight.
And I'm just like,
"Oh, I feel so sorry for you.
Why?"-
- I know
And that's exactly same experience I had
with Maquia because I
missed it in the cinemas
before I went to US but
it was on my flights
to US so I was like, "Perfect,
I can finally watch it."
- Yeah
- But in my head I was like, Oh no,
I have to watch it on this tiny screen
with these crappy ass
headphones that I had
because I didn't bring
my proper headphones.
But I watched it on the flight.
And I cried like a fucking bitch.
(Garnt laughing)
Oh my God.
Which makes me more,
it makes me more inclined to go watch it
on like a big screen.
- [Connor] Yeah, yeah
- Because I know if I
watched it on the big screen,
I would be crying even more like a bitch.
- You just get a text
from like row three, seat C,
that's like "Why you crying so damn loud?"
(Joey and Garnt laugh)
Like that meme template.
(both laugh)
- But yeah, if you don't know
do you know Maquia?
- Yeah, I know
- I know, I do
- So Maquia is this movie that was,
it wasn't advertised anywhere.
Was it?
- No, no, no.
It was very under the radar.
I think it was by PA.
Was it by PA Works?
No.
- It's not PA Works,
it was written and directed by Okada Mari.
- Yeah
- What was it about?
- She did Onahana-
- Oh, okay.
- Yeah
- She's basically known
as the anime writer
who is known for like all
those series that make you cry.
Yeah. She's like the
master of making you cry.
And Maquia was the movie that
it was a first directing debut.
But the thing is it wasn't
advertised anywhere.
Even in Japan, it wasn't
And I only found out about
it because my friend, Nabi.
- Yeah
- Let me know about it.
But, he let me know like two days
before it was gone from the cinema.
So I was like, cool.
I guess I can't watch that.
But then it was on the flight and yeah.
But that's the thing, right,
when you watch something
that's really funny
or very emotional on a plane-
- [Connor] Yeah.
- You can't just burst out
- Yeah you can, just fucking cry.
- I can't do that
- I'm in the middle seat.
Dude, I've cried on a plane.
- I was literally doing like a, this
Like trying to hold it in
(others laugh)
- They're like, "What you
want? Chicken or beef?"
(imitating sobs)
- Beef
(laughing)
- And I didn't want this white guy sitting
next to me to think,
"What the f-, this guy's
crying to a cartoon?"
(group laughs)
"What the hell's wrong with you?"
But yeah,
- What's like the riskiest thing
you've ever watched in the flight?
(Joey chuckles)
- What do you mean risky?
- I saw a guy on a plane
watching porn one time.
(others laughs)
I thought that was impressive.
- I remember the first time
I watched Prison School
on a flight.
That was, like,
- How the fuck did you do that?
- I was just like,
"Okay, I really want to
watch Prison School."
I downloaded it-
- You should put explain
how bad Prison School is
so that people can appreciate this.
- Okay, Prison School is like,
before there was inter-species
reviewers basically,
there was like Prison Schools.
(Joey laughs)
- It's one step away from Hentai.
- Yeah, for like how far
you could push ecchi.
I mean, there's a scene where
I think the guy pisses
on the girl accidentally,
- As you do, as you do.
It's fucking-
- I hate it when that happens.
- Yeah.
It's hilarious though, it's hilarious.
It's one of the funniest
ecchi anime that I have seen.
It was out like a few years ago.
Wasn't it?
How old was it when it came out?
- Twenty
seventeen, twenty eighteen.
- Yeah, cause I was a big fan
of the manga.
It was one of the few manga
that literally had me crying-laughing.
- Yeah.
- When I was reading it.
So I was like, I got to watch
this when it was out but-
- Except it has a very unfortunate ending.
Doesn't it?
- Yeah, yeah.
I haven't read to the ending yet.
- Don't spoil for me.
- It's a bit unfortunate.
- Yeah, yeah
- Because I was the same.
I read the manga and I thought this is
one of the funniest things I've ever read.
- Yeah
- And then just, Oh man,
I don't want to say too
much about the ending,
but it's, eh, not that great.
- So I was watching-
- How the hell though did
you watch that on the plane?
- Okay, so-
- Cause I felt ashamed
watching it by myself
- Wait, wait, wait, hold up.
Where were you sitting?
- Okay, I was sitting on the end, right.
And I had an iPad.
- Oh that's, wait so,
the whole, everybody walks gets to see it.
(Joey laughing)
- I don't care about them, right.
I care about the people
sitting next to me.
- Why? Why do you not care about them?
- And the person sitting next to me
was like a little kid.
(group laugh)
- You're like, "You're gonna love this
when you're older."
(Garnt laughs)
- So, at the beginning, right.
I was like, okay,
I was trying to be discreet
about it, all right.
I was on the iPad.
So I was trying to watch it as close
to my face as possible, you know?
(Joey laughing)
You know, like trying to be discrete.
So-
- Just putting blinders on this thing.
- Exactly.
And then it was like a 10 hour flight,
so my arms are going to get tired.
- [Joey] Yeah
- And then about like an hour in,
I was like, I don't fucking
give a shit anymore.
And, you know, if the
kid wants to look over,
there's some culture in his life.
- You wanna be a Chad kid, watch this.
(Joey laughs)
- Because, it wasn't the only
thing I watched, as well.
Cause the new season of Game
of Thrones was on as well.
So I thought, you know what,
I've already watched Prison School-
- Finish it off with a
Brazzers video, why not?
- [Joey] Why not, why not.
- I mean they can't blame me that time
because it was on their selection, right?
So, you know,
I'm sorry kid
or you're welcome kid.
- He's probably a massive
fan of the show now,
he's like,
(Garnt laughing)
thank you for opening me up to the world.
- Do you get to the point
on a long ass flight,
it's like a flight that's
over like eight hours, right?
Where you have one hour left
and you need to pick something to watch.
And that one hour of content
is like the worst watching.
- I don't even bother
with that kind of stuff.
If there's less than two
hours remaining on a flight,
I just don't even bother starting it.
- What do you do?
- I either read a book or sleep.
- What the fuck
- Yeah.
It's just like that Twilight zone-
- It's awful, I hate that-
- I hate it because it's the same
when I know I have to
do something in an hour
and I'm like I could
squeeze in an anime episode
in this time.
- It's like yeah.
- But I never do.
- I watch a random Family
Guy episode, I guess,
cause I hate myself.
Big Bang Theory episode
right after, why not?
- No, Big Bang Theory is never worth it.
- [Connor] No, no, no.
- It's not, you know that.
- When I see people
watching that on the plane
for like six hours straight,
I'm like, "What's wrong with you?"
(both laughs)
What went wrong?
Where this is the pick.
- I couldn't escape from The
Big Bang Theory thing, right?
Because of my surname.
- Bazinga!
- Yeah, so many people
are like, "Oh look, The Big Bang Theory."
(both laughs)
Or like, shut the fuck up.
No.
- Already hate the show.
- First of all, it's pronounced BAZINGA.
- Yeah
- All right
- Goddamn it, but yeah.
- That's gonna be on the Reddit now,
that's gonna-
- I remember seeing
you tweet the other day
that you don't realize how
much porn is on Twitter
until you see it in public.
- There's a lot of porn.
There's like, apart from
what you like as well,
we've already touched that topic.
But you know, when you're
sitting at home on a couch
you're just scrolling past,
you're just immune to this shit.
When you're sitting in
like a crowded train,
there's like a grandma to your left,
like another little kid to your right.
And you're like, "Man, there's just a girl
sucking dick right on my timeline."
(both laughs)
And it's just out there.
- Wait, like IRL?
- Huh?
- Like real life stuff.
- No, hentai, of course.
- I was gonna say it like "What
accounts are you following?"
(laughing)
Jesus, I though I was bad, goddamn.
- The reason I tweeted that
was the other day I was on the train.
And like that was, you
know, it's the worst right?
Where the image is cropped-
- No, I was about to say that
And you're like,
- And you're like, what's this?
And you open it,
and it's just like.
Cause what it was was two people, right?
Two people dressed as cowboys-
- [Joey] Yeah
- On the top, right?
So I opened it,
and then they were naked
from the bottom down.
(laughing)
Riding each other, like anime characters.
And because I was asleep,
it took me like four seconds to realize
what I was looking at.
But, like, I was holding
my phone like here.
So the two women who were sitting
next to me definitely saw.
And I was like, "Oh yeah,
I should not show this."
But okay, when I moved to
Japan the first week or so,
I was like, "Oh God I shouldn't share
what I'm looking at on my phone."
But now I'm just like,
"Hentai, hentai."
- Yeah
- I don't give a shit.
How do you think I find the
time to like all the hentai?
I do it on my commute.
- [Connor] You have to.
- Cause there's always that picture
where you're like, this is a 50/50.
Am I going to see titty?
Or is this just an ecchi picture?
You know what I mean?
Am I gonna see-
- Where it's just like,
it gets cut at like top
of the cleavage, right.
- Yeah yeah, like that right?
- I have nothing or
- And the facial expression,
it isn't like ahegao.
- It's like neutral right?
- It's just like a
slightly blushing picture.
(Joey laughs)
(voices overlapping)
- I know exactly what
you're talking about.
- It just like a slightly blushing picture
and be like, this could be
just a really nice piece of artwork
or it could be just be somebody
getting dicked from behind.
I don't know.
I have to click to find out, right.
(group laughs)
- It's like Reddit 50/50.
- Do you remember that time?
Can we tell that story?
- Yeah, you can tell him.
(both laughing)
- Garnt had like this photo of like
a woman who was in a Naruto costume.
And it was heavily cropped.
So all you could see was like
her shoulder upwards.
- It was Tsunade.
- Yeah.
- Cause how I found it was
Revel House,
Dee,
Deesidia,
had liked it.
And I thought, I saw the top half.
And I thought that's a good cosplay.
- It looked like a wholesome cosplay.
- Yeah yeah, I'll like that one.
- We were all sitting in
the living room, right.
Then Sydney barges and is like,
"Garnt, what the fuck have you liked?"
(group laughs)
And we were all like, why?
- Whoa, what's going on?
- What's going on?
So, we go and we expanded this image
and like 70% of it is
like her with her ass,
like full bare ass out.
- Yeah.
So, the exact pose she was doing,
it was like top half was like this
but then the bottom half was just-
(Joey and Connor laughing)
The bottom half was just like this.
(laughing continues)
- He was like, wait what?
So he goes, opens it.
He's like, "Oh shit."
And we all, we all went
to it to Twitter to look.
Because it's like six
of us in a living room.
And we all went to see it.
We all start fucking pissing ourselves.
(laughing).
Cause Garnt had basically retweeted this.
- [Joey] Oh my God.
- It was so funny.
I nearly fucking lost it.
I was laughing about that for like a week.
I'm gonna find the photo.
- Yeah.
- Speaking of weird stuff on Twitter,
you've been watching some
weird stuff on Youtube.
- Speaking on weird stuff on twitter,
stuff has been happening on Twitter.
(both laughing)
- Jesus Christ
- I mean, yeah.
YouTube, every single YouTube
community seems to be on fire.
We're doing pretty well
there, Anime YouTube right?
- Surprisingly
- So far.
I mean, it's kind of wild right now.
I mean, I don't really want
to get into the specifics
of all of that.
It's all speculation.
- I'm sure, if you guys
have a Twitter account,
you know what's been-
- Basically the whole
of YouTube is on fire
and, every day you log
in on Twitter, it's just-
- Twitter's just adding
the fuel to the fire.
- Yeah.
I mean, it's just, at this
point it's just exhausting,
right?
- It's so hard to keep up with.
And like, I obviously don't
wanna sit here and be like,
"Fuck the victims" or whatever.
I'm not trying to say that.
What I'm trying to say
is it's so exhausting.
- As like, I don't know,
shall I say consumer or
just person on the internet,
there's just too much
information for me to be able
to keep up with everything
that's going on now.
- There's only so many tweet
logs I can read it in a day
before I just start to the
big sigh starts to kick in.
- Yeah.
- Yeah
- I wanna care, right.
I want to support all these
people who are coming out
with all these statements,
but I also don't wanna help a situation
that I don't understand anything about.
- Yeah, yeah, exactly.
- And then also there's
just, there's just too many.
It feels like our brains are
being like D-DOSed right now,
by information.
- Yeah
- Cause like not only is the
world ending with Coronavirus
which we've just forgot about
- Yeah
- You know, we gonna
deal with all this shit
and figure that out and
it's just, oh my God.
It's impossible.
- I don't even know how the drama channels
are keeping up with all the
stuff that's coming out.
- They're just frothing
at the mouth, aren't they?
With all this content.
I mean, I made a joke on Twitter saying,
"The only people benefiting from 2020
are the drama and news channels."
But, it really does seem
that's the case, you know.
- Yeah
- Because everybody else is just
so sick of what's happening.
And I feel bad saying that, all right.
Because as you said-
- I just wish it didn't happen.
You know what I mean?
- Right, right
- It's tragic that the bar
for being a somewhat
decent content creator
is just not touching kids now.
- It's just keeping your
genitals in your pants.
- Yeah, yeah
- You know, it's sad
that it's come to that.
(Connor chuckles)
- All right.
- It's just, all right.
I guess just making content
is not even thing anymore.
- Because, remember like five years ago
when it was controversial to
have a sponsor in your video.
And now it's kind of "controversial",
if you do something
really weird with kids.
And it's just like, what's
- I don't know
- I mean, YouTube changed
and evolved so much.
Thinking about, just like,
I'm going on like a content perspective.
- Yeah.
- You know I mean?
There's always this kind
of like YouTube-meta
about the content you should make.
Cause I remember like commentary channels
or drama channels didn't really
exist like five years ago.
Because, I don't know.
Cause I remember thinking,
'Why would anyone be
interested in YouTubers
talking about other YouTubers?'
- I guess it's like
the way that, you know,
the reason why TMZ exists, right?
- Yeah, yeah
- It gets to a point, right.
where YouTube got so big
and you can only like there people-
I mean, I basically only
watch YouTube at this point.
I watch anime, I watch Netflix but.
It's like 80% YouTube,
right, what I watch.
- Yeah.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- It would make sense that
then a market would appear
for being able to just
talk about YouTuber drama
and dumb shit that YouTubers do.
Cause, my God, do they do some dumb shit.
- Yeah, and a lot of them, unfortunately,
get away with a lot of it as well.
- And I think it's just because
there was not as many eyes
on just what YouTubers
were doing back then.
Cause it was just like,
why are you talking about a YouTuber?
They're no celebrity.
They don't have any power.
- As much as all these YouTubers
like to wish they were a celebrity.
(both laughing)
- We're main stream.
- Yeah, but I don't know,
like Twitter is just been.
I've always enjoyed Twitter
because I've always said to people,
it's kind of a nice in-between
of social and business.
At least in terms of like
as a YouTuber using Twitter.
- I don't understand what, like,
a regular person would need Twitter for.
- Right?
- I think it's a cesspit.
- I never used Twitter
before I started YouTube.
- No, no, nor did I.
- I never cared about Twitter
or anything like that.
But, I think as a YouTuber, it's kinda of-
- You have no choice.
- It's almost required at this point.
- Yeah.
- Next to a YouTube channel.
- I doubt we would be friends, right,
if we didn't all meet on Twitter.
- Yeah, nah.
- Socialize with each other.
- To me, Twitter is just
basically Facebook for
influencers online, I guess.
I get to follow what
everyone else is doing.
Not just in my own circles,
but in like other circles as well.
Because that's basically the only reason
I go on Twitter apart from
ludes and memes, you know what I mean?
- Porn and you know
- The rest of Twitter just makes me
(sighs)
- Yeah.
- Sometimes, you know what I mean?
- I totally get it.
- You can't have a debate anything,
really, on Twitter.
- No, no
- And people aren't interested in
having their opinions changed.
- The moment you join in on an
argument you've already lost.
- That's why I like, obviously,
we're all human, we all
have opinions on things.
But I think the reason
why most of us just don't
comment on anything.
Cause it's like if you comment, you lose.
- Yeah.
- If you get involved, you lose.
- We can't be fucked
joining on this losing battle, right.
It's just a waste of energy.
- It's like, if I want it to get involved,
I don't think Twitter
is the right platform-
- No, no
- To get involved.
Like a lot of things, like
some things yeah definitely.
But I feel like there are other platforms
or other means that can,
that you can use
- Yeah, definitely
- To get involved.
- And it's just like,
it's crazy how even the
most agreeable statements
can become controversial on Twitter.
Like I saw, someone who was just like,
"Yeah, don't fuck kids."
And there was somehow
people in the comments.
(Garnt laughing)
- How dare you?
- Somehow, there was
someone commenting like,
as a playing devil's advocate,
it's like what?
This is just like drink water.
I thought this was a thing
that everyone was just
understood was the thing to do.
But, somehow
- Unfortunately common sense,
nowadays, it's not as common
as we'd like to think it is,
all right.
- Which is why I just,
again, even if I think
me commenting on something or like,
getting involved with a
drama, it's like a slam dunk.
I'm like, it's not worth it.
Cause it's like four people who are like,
I don't know though.
- You could say you got
to drink water to survive
and people would be like,
"But I like drinking Coke."
(Connor and Joey laugh)
"Can I not do, are you telling
me that I can't drink Coke?"
- You fucking right wing.
You like water-
- Coke once water,
right?
- It's just, I hate it so much.
- Yeah, it's unfortunate
- It's kinda why,
I just kind of like,
switch off and post my occasional memes
to Twitter and get on with my YouTube.
- I feel for me,
it's been like that for
the past couple of years.
And it's just kind of gradually
gotten worse and worse until today.
I mean, before I wouldn't hesitate
to post an opinion about something,
regardless of how controversial was.
- Yeah I notice,
you don't really post your
opinions much anymore.
- No, because every time I do-
- You got a lot of shit.
- There's always some group of people
who's just so quick to
coming on to me like,
"Oh, no, you're a terrible person
for saying this very personal opinion."
- You are, Joey.
(both laughs)
- Yeah, apparently, according
to the Internet I am.
And now I just, I don't know.
There's so much, as you said,
there's so much I want to say
but I guess that's the double-edged sword
of having a big following.
- Yeah, yeah
- And a quote-unquote
influence on the internet.
- Yeah, yeah, exactly.
- I think I've become content with
not having to say my opinion.
I mean, you look at like
JK Rowling and you're like
please, stop.
- Yeah
(Joey and Garnt laugh)
- Please stop saying your opinion, right.
But like, that's the thing, right.
You get famous or whatever
and you think my opinion
deserves to be heard.
It's a right for it to be heard.
And it's like, shut the fu-
No one gives a fuck about what you think.
- Sometimes no one gives a shit.
- I think like that's
the biggest reality check
as a YouTuber is like just learning
that no one gives a
fuck of what you think.
Cause just make videos for me.
- Yeah, pretty much.
(Connor laughs)
- Cause I mean like, for me,
I see myself the same way
as I did like 10 years ago,
we're all just fucking normal guys
who had like the same fucking life
as most other people watching this.
And I went through fucking university.
No one gave a shit about
my opinion back then.
Why would people give a
shit about my opinion now?
Because I have shitty opinions on Anime.
That just doesn't make
sense to me, you know.
- I just don't think my opinion
is better than anyone's.
I think my opinion is just
as shitty as some people.
- And isn't that hilarious
how so many people
who are against like channels like us
who are so quick to be like,
"Oh, he thinks that his
opinion is so much more grander
than everybody else's because
he has a large following.
He has influence on the internet."
And yet we never say or mean that ever.
Like they're putting words in our mouth.
- I mean, it happens.
I just kind of accepted
that stuff happens like that
but I don't get too beat up about it.
- Yeah, I mean, it's part of like you said
the double-edged sword of
having a very large audience.
Like we could not talk
to this large an audience
if they were like in real
person, there in real life.
And you're going to get like,
something you're gonna say is gonna
inevitably get misconstrued
or something like that.
And some people are
just not gonna like you.
- Yeah
- We talked about it last time.
- It's a hard thing to learn
that you're just gonna have to accept that
you're not gonna be universally liked.
- Yeah.
- It's weird.
But, you know, what's a one good example
is that I remember.
you know when you first
start uploading videos
when you got that first
dislike and you were like,
"Huh?
Huh!
Whomst disliked this?
Tell me thy name."
You know, you're like,
you want to find out
why they disliked it.
- Yeah.
- And then like,
if you're looking at
like down here right now,
you can see like 120 or
like 300 or a thousand,
I don't know how many
views we have, right?
- Yeah.
- You just accept really quickly
that you're gonna have
like 200 dislikes straight away.
and you don't know why.
- Yeah,
- I don't know why 30
people disliked my video
when it goes live, but
it happens to everyone.
And I want to know why.
(Garnt laughs)
But it's something that as a YouTuber,
you just come to accept.
But I guarantee if any of
you start a YouTube channel,
you'll know when you
get that first disliked.
Cause it's gotten sting and
you're going to be like,
"Argh!"
- But, I've always said to people who,
because so many people
when I go to panels or
conventions or whatnot.
The question that I'm sure
all three of us get asked
is 'How do you start a YouTube channel?'
Like 'What tips do you have
for a beginning YouTube channel?'
And I've always said to people
that the moment you start
getting dislikes in your video
is when you know you've made it.
(Garnt laughs)
It's, because it's true.
Because now-
- It's actually true
- Because-
- Or you're fucked up
- Yeah, or you fucked up really bad.
But, if your video start to get
maybe like one or two
dislikes, it's like, you know-
- [Connor] Yeah, yeah.
- Maybe 10 times the
amount of likes. right?
- Yeah, right.
- Then that means you know you've made it,
because now you're reaching
a wide enough audience
that you won't be able
to please everybody.
And that's the end goal really
for content creators, right?
- [Connor] Oh definitely.
- Because I think it's kind of futile
that there are some
content creators out there
who are just really desperate
to try and please everybody.
And I always just want
to tell those people,
"Dude, it's not gonna work."
Like, you just have to accept
that if you're on the internet,
people are going to
hate you for no reason.
And you just have to accept that.
- Yeah.
- Like it's, I mean, you
read the comments, right.
And you see that some people
make really odd conclusions
from your behavior.
(Garnt laughs)
- [Joey] Right.
- That are really odd and general
and someone, no matter what you do,
and what kind of personality you show,
one person is going to
perceive it in a bad way.
- [Joey] Right.
- Like it's gonna happen-
- Like, if we were just to take
all the videos where we've collaborated,
apparently Connor's like
manically depressed.
(Garnt And Joey laugh)
- Because I just have a face
where like naturally, I
always get this in person.
People think I'm mad at them,
but I just have a face
naturally that's just like.
- You just have a
- Yeah, yeah.
- You just have a resting bitch face.
- Yeah, I've always had
that since I was like a kid-
- But, there's always that one
comment when it's just like,
"Why is Connor so depressed?"
- It's got like a thousand upvotes, right?
- "Is he just not happy to be there?
- It was on like your Engrish video.
- Yeah, yeah
- Where it's like, okay,
people like "Yo Connor,
not, like, super energetic."
It's like, it's not my video.
I don't want to be that asshole
who's like "It's about me."
You know, it's like, if I'm
on like Joey's channel, right.
Joey's doing his intro,
I'm not going to try and interject.
It's his fucking intro.
- You gonna be like "Hello guys"
- I'm not so self-centered
where I think that I'm
on someone else's video
that I have to be the center of attention.
I'm there to be on Joey's channel.
Right,
- Right.
- I don't see it as like,
I need to entertain.
- We're not all like
Guy Fieri every episode.
- I'll contribute when I can join in.
But I'm not gonna cut you off.
- Yeah
- Yeah, right
- It's your channel, right.
Because it would piss me off
if someone was like trying to really
show me up on my own channel.
Like bro, come on, we're collabing,
just be normal.
- This is my channel, alright.
- Yeah.
- Know your place.
- Because wouldn't be weird, right,
if you're doing a video with someone,
let's say you're a new YouTuber
and your friend comes over,
and, you're like, let's make a video.
And your friend is like his normal self.
The moment that camera turns on,
he's like, "Yo, what's up?"
You're like, "Wow, what the fuck man."
(Joey And Garnt laugh)
"What happened?"
That would be weird, right.
Cause obviously I'm not
like that all the time.
- Yeah, yeah
- It's just something that's
like, I don't know, man.
Okay, question for you,
I get this every single time I do
like a panel at convention.
I get the question that goes,
"How do you deal with hate?"
Because I'm of the philosophy,
you never deal with it,
you just come to accept it.
- Yeah
- Right, you just learn
to just get over it.
Do you remember how you-
- No, like that's like a very,
I'm like I feel very passionate about this
because I feel like there's
no right answer for this.
And I feel like the right answer is that
we just basically got to
check ourselves online
and just don't be a fucking dick.
All right, because it's
unfortunate, right?
Because I get this
I get asked the question a lot as well.
And every creator I've talked to,
there's no solution, right.
You just get used to it, right.
You just, you just got
to ignore it, right.
And to me, that's fucking insane.
(Joey And Connor laugh)
Cause that's not a solution.
That's a coping mechanism,
you know what I mean?
- Yeah,
- Yeah, exactly.
- But that's the only thing we can do
when we have to deal with hate.
- Yeah
- I'm sure she won't mind if I share this
but Jessica Nigri-
- Yeah, yeah.
- Really good friend of mine.
I asked her this-
- Damn, is that a flex?
(all laugh)
- Anime flex.
I asked this question to her because
when she blew up,
she was getting noticed by everybody.
But at the same time, when
you blow up in that sense,
you also gain a lot of
haters unfortunately.
That's just how it works, right.
And so I remember,
I think Aki asked her the question of,
"How do you, how did
you get through that?"
Because we all saw, as a third person,
just how brutal her haters were-
- She got a lot of hate.
- Yeah, she got a lot of
hate in her primetime.
And so Aki asked her, she was like,
"So, how do you like deal with it?"
And I think Jessica said
it in the most perfect way.
And she just said,
"It's not that you deal,
you do end up dealing with it,
but it never stops hurting."
- No, no, it-
- And I think that just
perfectly sums it up,
you learn to deal with it
but it never stops hurting.
Every time, if you see
that one hate comment,
that's just, it just hits you in that,
the worst spot possible.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- Like you'll learn to deal with it
because you've seen so
many examples of it.
- But, no matter how immune you are,
there's always that one
comment every so often
that comes up that you're just like.
- [Joey] Aww.
- "Oh, that just ruined my whole day."
And I thought I was above this,
but you're never above it.
- [Joey] No, you're never.
- I'm a person who I'd say,
I'm not self-conscious about many things.
I'd say, on average, for people I speak to
there's maybe like one or two things
I'm self-conscious about.
- Yeah,
- And it's just like.
Dude, they consider whatever they want,
but if they hit that one thing
that I was worrying about that one day.
- Yeah.
- That shit hurts.
- Yeah
- I think one story that I've experienced
on like a secondhand experiences.
I'm sure Sydney is fine
with me telling this story
is that she was, she became a meme.
- Okay.
- Yeah.
- This was back when cringe
culture was like at its prime.
- Yeah.
- So she made like, she made
a video when she was a kid,
that was like, it was kind of
like a parody of like yanderes
and just like the anime weeb kind of girl.
But it was to the point
when people couldn't
tell that it was satire.
- Cause they don't know the personality.
- Yeah, yeah
They don't know the person.
She wasn't really a YouTuber back then.
She was just a girl on the internet.
- Girl who uploaded a video.
- Yeah. Yeah, exactly.
Then years later, Leafy
featured it in a video.
- Yeah. I remember that
- And that just fucking blew up.
- Yeah, yeah
- She became a meme and I like,
I was on YouTube at this point.
So I know like the right and wrong things
that you can do online.
But even seeing it from
a secondhand perspective,
it was like, it was hard.
Because she'd wake up
and she would just get death
threats every single day.
I had to just delete Twitter,
delete Facebook, because it
got to the point when people
from her school were
messaging her about it.
That's how widespread it was.
And like, I've never
talked about this publicly
but it was fucking hard.
Because like I love Sydney
and like I did not know the right way
to deal with it.
So, what I did was I was like,
okay, this is the only way
I could make it a bit better.
So I wrote like a parody
video for her, which is
if you've seen Sydney's video called like
"How 2 be a Tsundere" or
something along those lines,
where she basically satirizes it.
That was my way of trying
to help her get out of it.
Because you know on the Internet,
if you say something is bad
or if you say you're hurting,
that's only going to
make it 10 times worse.
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah.
- So I tried to deal with it
by just trying to make a joke out of it.
And to an extent, it worked.
But to this day,
Sydney still like sometimes
she gets notifications on her Facebook
or her Twitter and
it's just...
It affects her.
It never went away.
- [Joey] Yeah, I bet.
- Because we went through
like a whole year period
where she was just afraid of social media.
Because she was afraid
of opening up a message,
and then someone new was like mocking her
or someone she knew
personally was mocking her.
And it's like,
this is why I like, feel really strongly
about this because I don't
feel like there's a right way
you can deal with it.
- [Joey] No.
- The only way we can deal with it
is just to make sure
that we, as a community,
don't act shitty online.
And just know that there is a person
behind that avatar and we can,
it's so easy to forget,
a lot of the times, even
for us, you see a number,
we see our view counts,
and we're just like,
that's just the number.
But like behind every number,
behind every avatar,
there is someone there.
And especially with what's
been going on online nowadays,
you know I mean, and some of the stuff
that's been happening on
Twitter and YouTube recently.
I think it's super important that,
we as a community, try to just act better.
- Yeah
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Because there's no way to regulate this.
So the only way I can think of
is just to promote just acting better
and being better online.
- Since when did it become so hard
for people on the internet to just act
like a normal fucking human being?
- It's...
weird
because the mentality
people have is just strange.
Like my old housemate used to
do, like, K-pop dance videos.
And like, there may be like, I don't know,
like 20-30 comments on most videos.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- And I remember there was
one time when someone said
that she looked like chubby
in one of the dances.
And then she replied being like,
"What the fuck?"
- Yeah.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- And then this person replied saying,
"Oh, I never thought you'd see it."
- Yeah. Yeah.
That's the thing, right.
- That's the weird mentality
that I think some people have
where they think,
"Oh, they're never gonna see this."
Like, no, we'll see it.
(Joey and Garnt laugh)
- Yeah
- [Joey] Will see it.
- And I think every YouTuber has said that
time and time again.
We see it, we see it.
But then a part of me is like,
'Is that like a bad thing to say
that we gonna see it?'
Because then is that gonna
make them comment more?
I just feel like this is a...
This is a problem that's never
going to have a solution.
- No
- Except that just,
maybe if we keep repeating the message of
"Be a little careful."
Cause, I'm not going to get
mad or upset about anything.
I might get a little bothered,
but I'm gonna be fine.
But-
- [Joey] Yeah.
- With some of the unfortunate stuff
that has happened recently with, you know,
a lot of online personalities,
some taking their own life.
- Yeah, exactly
- It's really, it's pretty terrifying that
to think that maybe some of my friends
might not be able to handle that, right.
- Yeah, and that's why,
I think I'm sure we can all agree that
we all very strongly
advocate for mental health
among YouTubers.
- [Connor] Oh yeah.
- And there's a reason why
so many YouTubers do have
mental health issues.
Is because of stuff like this.
- Because of this.
Cause we're never like,
us,
just as human beings,
evolution never taught us how to deal with
(Connor chuckles)
50 million people sending
you a clown emotes.
- Yeah, exactly.
- You know what I mean.
- You don't learn this in school.
- No, no
- You just have to learn
through trial and error.
And unfortunately, a lot of the times,
some people are just not
psychologically equipped
to handle a certain amount of hate.
- [Connor] Yeah, yeah.
- Or a certain amount of
backlash or anything like that.
And yeah, I mean, you know.
- Do you ever find that we like,
did you ever like do YouTube
or like watch YouTube videos
to like escape real life sometimes?
- Yeah, that's what it was.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- But, like now sometimes you feel like
you have to switch off Twitter
and switch off YouTube and
escape that in real life.
- Oh yeah, yeah.
- You know what I mean?
- Like isn't that messed up?
(Garnt chuckles)
- It's a bit weird
- It's weird
cause it's so easy,
just like going back
to Satoshi Kon, right.
It is totally like getting
sucked into another world.
- Oh yeah, yeah.
- Right?
It is a separate world where
you exist in that world.
And the best way I can
describe getting a lot of hate
is it just, I don't know why,
but it just feels suffocating.
- Oh yeah.
- You know what I mean?
- You could be sitting
in your living room.
No one's there, but you
could just feel suffocated
just with all these comments
being thrown onto you.
It's really hard
and there's no right way to
deal with it as a person.
You just-
- Because isn't it interesting that
we could upload a video
and it get 200 dislikes
and we're saying, "Oh,
it's only 200 people."
- [Connor] Yeah.
- But if you think about it in real life,
that's like walking into
a fully packed cinema
and all those people just
immediately turning to you
and saying "Fuck you".
(Garnt laughs)
That's what it feels like.
That's what 200 dislikes looks like.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- And it's so weird,
how so many YouTubers are
just kind of numb to that now.
- It's also weird
'cause there are a lot of YouTubers
who never got off the ground,
who I think should have.
- Yeah.
- Because it really crippled them.
- I don't know if she's
will be okay with me
talking about it.
I'm just gonna fucking do it.
So, you know, like the 'Hit-Or-Miss' girl?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Remember that was a
thing like two years ago?
- The one you interviewed?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
- So, I should pretty introduce
how I actually met her first
so that we can go into it.
So before she blew up
as the Hit-Or-Miss girl,
she met me at a convention
because she was a fan.
And one of my friends after she blew up
was like, "Yo, on her Instagram,
she's got a picture with you."
And I'm like, "What the fuck?
I don't know this girl."
And then I went to an Instagram,
and sure enough,
she had a picture with me.
So I Dm'ed her and we were chatting.
And I was like, "Yeah, if you
need any help with anything."
Cause normally when I
speak to new YouTubers
or YouTubers who are blowing up,
I'm like, "Hey, if you need any help,
you know, with negotiating ad deals,
you need help dealing with anything.
Let me know, I'll give you advice.
I'll help you, get you all sorted."
It's chill
- Right.
- Cause it's hard.
I wish someone had helped me.
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah.
- So then, you know,
she had all these plans
and stuff to make
content,
which I think she should have
because she was in a very rare position
where she could have gotten a career for,
at least like 5-10 years-
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Off the fame, the level of
fame that she had at that time
- Oh no, definitely.
- It was insane.
- Yeah, yeah.
- If you were around this time,
you'll know she was like the thing.
- Yeah, yeah
- Right.
It was, I mean, my video was garbage
and he got a million views.
(Joey and Connor laugh)
It was a terrible video.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Right.
- It was purely based
off her face and her name
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah.
- A million views just like
that, right, not even a problem.
And there was compilations
of her doing anything
with a million plus views on YouTube.
- Right.
- Cause she didn't upload anything.
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah
- And people wanted it.
And I was telling her, you know,
we filmed a video for her channel.
I was trying to help get her started.
But she made a mistake,
which I tell other YouTubers,
everyone's going to be like,
"What do you mean Connor?"
Because you did this."
Is don't make a fucking Discord server.
(Joey and Garnt laugh)
I think having a Discord
server that you're involved in
like you're actually moderating yourself,
is the quickest way to get
people to start disliking you.
It is cause if you have to ban someone,
they'll be like, "CDawgVA,
he banned me for no reason.
Fuck that guy."
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Right, so she made a Discord server
and bear in mind,
she was already like kind
of a target on 4Chan.
- Yeah.
- [Joey] Yeah, right.
- Because they wanted to find
out information about it so-
- [Joey] Yeah.
- This became like cesspit of a Discord.
I know she'll probably say that it isn't,
but like I've seen a few-
- As a third person.
- I've been around the internet.
I know a cesspit when I see one.
(Garnt laughing)
I know a 4Chan breeding ground-
- [Joey] Right.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And they were out for blood for her.
Like they doxxed her like multiple times,
they were finding out where she was.
They found her boyfriend
which she hadn't revealed.
And they were making it
hell for him and her.
They were like threatening
that they were gonna come to her house
then they would mentioned
their address and stuff.
And like that was a, I
reckon, her chance of
having anything was ruined
because she was so preoccupied
with all this shit and
trying to deal with it.
- Oh yeah.
- Of people just hating on
her, finding her address,
saying horrible things about her,
saying that she was a dude all the time.
It was horrible.
And like...
Many times she would message me
like really upset about it being like,
"What do I do?
I don't know what to do, man."
- Yeah.
- Countless horrible stories.
I don't know what I can share
and what I can't share
so I just won't share anything.
- [Joey] Right.
- Right.
- Just really horrible things
that was happening to her
left right and center.
Cause she didn't set up the
precautions to deal with this.
- [Joey] Oh no.
- And she didn't know what she was doing.
- Yeah.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- And-
- Because even then,
there's only so many
precautions you can set up.
- Yeah, yeah
I mean, the bigger you get,
you normally limit ways that
people can communicate with you
- Yeah, yeah.
- You normally make it very difficult
for people to be able to
one-to-one talk with you.
- Yeah.
- Also, because it's
just very hard to talk
to that many people with
that big an audience.
- If I opened my DMs on Twitter
and I was like, "Hey guys, open DMs."
- Yeah
- [Joey] Yeah.
- My DMs would be pretty much unusable
within two days, right.
- Yeah.
- So, and it's just
like, it's really tragic
because she easily
could have had a career.
- Oh no, she could have.
- And she's watching this now thinking,
"Wow Connor, you should
have told me this."
But it's like, how can I
tell you to make a career?
Right?
- [Joey] Right.
- I did my best to help.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- And push
- If she's not the one acting on it,
then there's not much you can do.
- But she wanted to,
I remember she wanted to.
I don't know if she
really wanted to or not,
but there was definitely
opportunity there.
And it was just, it was
really sad seeing hate-
- Like hearing this, I
understand how hard it can be
especially in the situation
she was in because, yeah.
- That was a rare situation.
That doesn't happen, right.
- Yeah, it doesn't happen often.
But you know, when you get
to that point when it's just,
you're scared to go online,
going back to what I
experienced with Sydney.
I was like, I had to like
just uninstalling everything.
Like I remember, I was
I took the phone off of her and I'm like,
"Okay, just let me go
through the hate comments.
And I'll make sure it's safe for you."
And man, going through the
phone on behalf of her,
I felt fucking shitty.
- Yeah
- Because some of the
things people can send
are fucking horrible, okay.
Especially back then.
So I can totally understand being like,
dude I just don't want
any involvement in this.
Because if you go into that
thinking that you can
make a career out of this,
with that kind of toxic environment.
I think, at that point, you do
yourself more harm than good.
- Oh yeah.
- In the longterm.
And I think, there is always a time
when you can make a career online
but I think there is a
healthy way to go about it.
- Absolutely.
- And the less healthy way to go about it.
- I mean,
I think there was definitely
room for her to do it.
- Yeah.
- It's just
- Oh no, I think that was if-
- Even if, okay.
I'm not trying to compare,
but like, it's like a similar situation
with the Neekolul girl.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- She became a huge streamer now.
- Yeah.
- And I think at the peak
of the Hit-Or-Miss thing,
it was bigger than the Neekolul girl-
- Oh yeah.
- So I think it was easy, but
she just didn't do anything.
And her parents were also pretty
much like against anything.
- Yeah
- Didn't take any of this seriously.
- Cause the thing is,
if you want to make a career out of it,
you do need like a very good
understanding of the internet.
- Yeah, which is why-
- And know how it operates.
- Which is why I was
trying to help her out.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Not like, hey, and you know,
there was also like a ton of
opportunistic YouTubers
coming out of the woodwork
to try and get that piece
of the pie, if you will.
- [Joey] Right.
- Yeah.
- She would tell me about all the stuff
that some of these YouTubers are saying.
And I was like "Oh my God!,
some of these dudes are slimy, bro."
- Yeah. Yeah.
- It's just, I don't even know.
- Internet's a scary place man.
- It is.
Which is like, I'm so glad
I didn't just blow up.
I'm so glad I got,
the slow climb.
- The slow burn.
- Yeah, yeah
- Because I got to make every mistake,
I got to make all the fuck-ups,
I got to learn everything myself.
Before I actually had to
learn all that, right.
So I can deal with it now,
because I learnt it all.
But a lot of these people who blow up,
it's like, "How the fuck do you,
how do you learn how to
negotiate an ad deal?
How do you learn how to deal
with like a hundred plus hate comments?"
- Yeah, yeah
- Yeah,
- How do you know?
No one tells you how to deal with this
I don't get much hate, but you know,
everyone gets a little bit.
- This episode of Trash Taste is sponsored
by BOOK WALKER.
Have you guys heard of Book Walker?
- Oh no.
- Never heard of Book Walker.
- Daddy Book Walker?
- Daddy Book Walker
(Joey and Garnt laugh)
- The boys that got their selves Yeezys.
(Joey and Garnt continue laughing)
- If you guys don't know
Book Walker right now
is doing a Summer Anima kick-over event
where you can get 10-30% coin back
on the following series,
such as "Uzaki chan Wants to Hang Out!"
Have you seen that one
that's about to be animated?
- What about this next one?
SWORD ART Online Alicization.
- Oh my God.
- Now you know what I'm gonna be watching.
I'm gonna be watching that one
- Have never heard of that one
We also have RENT-A-GIRLFRIEND, as well,
which is a pretty popular manga series,
that's about to get an anime added to it.
- I'm like at the time of recording,
we haven't watched the anime yet
but I'm so hyped for this one.
- Yeah,
- Like this is,
I feel like this is gonna be the next big,
harem, kind of, best girl...
Best girl kind of show.
- It's gonna be as the name
suggests the Trashiest.
(Garnt And Connor laugh)
You see what I did there?
- It kinda sound a little trashy.
- It is a little bit,
but here's one that's not trashy, Re:ZeRo.
- Okay. I'm hype, I'm high.
There's my waifu R.E.M, I'm hyped.
- Are you fucking serious?
- What do you mean by serious?
(Garnt laughs)
- I mean, look,
I'm gonna be the 1% to
flaunt over Beatrice, okay?
I'm sorry.
(Garnt hits table)
- Okay, take it.
- Yes, oh my God,
I thought I was the only one.
Oh my God.
- Yes.
- This is like, when two
pedophiles meet each other.
(Joey And Garnt laugh)
- I thought I was the only one.
Yes, Beatrice, best girl.
- No, not only that.
We also have Neon Genesis
Evangelion, the manga series.
Or if you want some high
quality light novels,
we also have,
"MY YOUTH ROMANTIC COMEDY
IS WRONG AS I EXPECTED".
Amazing light novel series
but amazing anime series, as well.
- Yes, you definitely
check out season three.
And if you haven't, if you don't know it,
then either read the light novels
or catch up on season one and two.
Cause season three is
gonna be fucking hype.
- Also we have the MONSTER
GIRL DOCTOR and FIRE FORCE.
So, if you like that,
and a whole lot more.
Then, make sure to go over to Book Walker.
And once again, thank you
for sponsoring today's episode.
- Back to the video.
So, I mean like, here's a question
for you guys then,
like what do you think of the state
of Anime YouTube right now?
And do you think it's in a healthy spot?
- Well, I mean I guess
compared to what happening
on other communities right now.
- [Garnt] I mean.
- Compared to the SMASH community,
Anime YouTube is like the Virgin Mary.
- Nintendo is probably thinking,
"Holy fuck, we dodged
a bullet from being-"
- Super Smash Bros is for good boys
and girls, remember kids.
(group laugh)
Yeah, I mean, there was
a point, I will admit,
there was a point where I would look
at the Ani-Tube community
and I was like, "Fuck this community".
(group laugh)
Like, legitimately, there
was just like some people,
and just like, some fan
bases as well especially.
Just some groups of people,
where I was just like,
"Man, we don't need that
kind of mentality in here."
But what can you do, right?
The Ani-Tube community,
or at least the anime community online,
especially in the last 5 years or so,
has been growing so much more rapidly.
- Yeah.
- Like 5 years ago, it was
still very much a niche.
But nowadays, it's gotten to the point now
where other communities are
starting to recognize the size
and power of the anime
and Ani-Tube community.
So obviously with that is gonna come
a lot of slimy behavior from
a group of people, right?
- Yeah, I mean like, it's been weird
seeing the Ani-Tube
grow as much as it has.
Because I remember there was a point
where you could just
point to a group of people
and be like, this is
the Ani-Tube community.
This is the Anime YouTube community.
And then everyone kind of
tried to get along together
because the group was small enough
where you would know
everyone in the community.
- [Joey] Right.
- So, you'd try to network
and everything like that.
- I mean, and we all tried
to do that at one point,
didn't we?
- No, no.
And then it got to a point
where the community grew too big
for it to be under one banner.
- Right.
- And there were too many
different personalities
for everyone to be able to mix.
And it's,
I feel like,
that happened like 3-4 years ago.
And now, I feel like with Anime YouTube,
it's a lot of different small communities
that I'd grouped under one
general banner, I guess.
- Well, it's like the
gaming community, right?
When it first started,
I'm sure all these small creators
would come together and band.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- But now that there are
just so many of these groups,
it's like small groups
within small groups.
- [Garnt And Connor] Yeah.
- I mean it's, I bet
the Fortnite streamers
don't talk to the CSGO streamers.
- Right, right.
- You know what I mean.
It's like, it's different.
And it's the same with anime, right.
Like, dude, I don't know any
fucking Dragon Ball YouTubers,
but I know there are.
And like the Naruto YouTubers,
they all keep to themselves and stuff.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Yeah.
- It's weird.
- But it's weird
because it used to be a point
when if you made anime content-
- At all, yeah
- You were an anime YouTuber.
And now there's people like Critical
making anime content, other people outside
making anime content as well.
And it's just become
a bit more widespread.
And it's less-
- Everyone talks about anime.
- It's more general now
- Yeah
- You don't necessarily have to advocate
as an Anime YouTuber for you
to make anime content now.
Everybody can make anime content.
- Yeah, yeah.
I always felt like, on
the opposite end of you,
where you were, I've always
been like a core of it
because you wanna be first,
you're always one of the biggest.
You've grown with it.
I felt like I was always
on the outskirts of it,
where like, I was never friends
with anyone in it, really.
- The 93%.
(Garnt laughs)
- Well, I mean,
the only friend I did have
turned out to do some
really fucked up shit.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Should I tell the story?
I may have mentioned it.
- I mean I know the story.
- Yeah, go for it.
- Yeah fuck it, I'm going to say it.
So when I first started
making Black Butler content,
which if you don't know
what Black Butler is,
it's a Victorian era anime
about a servant and a butler.
- It's 93%: The Anime.
(Garnt laughs)
- It's very targeted
towards a female audience.
When I started doing it,
I would do the voice of Sebastian.
Sebastian.
- [Joey And Garnt] Sebastian.
- And I would do prank calls,
and I would call people up
and I would tell them,
"Oh my goodness, my
refrigerator's running"
or blah, blah, blah.
- There's a group of people
watching this right now
that are just frothing from the nostalgia.
(Garnt laughs)
They're like, "HE DID
THE SEBASTIAN VOICE!"
- Yeah, yeah, "I'm simply
one hell of a butler".
That line-
(Joey screams)
- Right so, I would do a lot
of Sebastian content, right.
And so, in the show, there's a Sebastian
and then there's a Ciel, right.
So I thought to myself,
"I need to find someone
who sounds exactly like this guy,
because I sound exactly like this guy."
- [Joey And Garnt] Yeah, yeah.
- And I found a person who
insisted on being called Ciel,
that's how into this character they were.
- [Joey And Garnt] Right.
- Right.
And at the time, they had a big following
and we were known together.
And everyone just thought
we were best mates,
but like, I just thought they
were really fucking weird.
First of all, I used to
just do the Sebastian thing
and then the moment the camera turned off,
"I'm gonna go play games, uh,
I'm done pretending to be a British guy."
I mean, I am a British guy
but I mean I dumped him
to be a British butler.
But for them, it was like-
- They were living it.
- They never turned off the persona
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah.
- You couldn't not call them that
because they would be
like, "What the fuck?
I'm called Ciel. You'll call me Ciel."
(Garnt cackles)
And bear in mind, this person's like,
I don't know, 26?
27?
They should have, it was weird.
27 year old should not be like
living with their parent-
- "I'm not Dave, I'm Ciel."
- Right so,
it was weird
and one time they came to London
and we hung out
and it was really, really, really weird.
- Oh, so you met him in person?
- I met him once in person,
cause I kinda felt like
they'd help me out.
Because we did a lot of
Black Butler content,
but then they started to be really shitty.
And they used to, like, flake on me.
- And then-
- Yeah.
- Okay, one thing they did
that was really suss was that,
when we collab together, you
don't ask for money from me.
We're collabing, we both
had YouTube channels.
When they were on my channel,
they would ask me to pay them.
- What?
- And I used to be like,
"That's not how YouTube works.
When you collab, it's a mutual interest."
- [Joey] Yeah.
- But you know, they were
like, "No, we wanna get paid."
Because my videos were doing better.
But I'm like that means that
your channel will get a huge-
So that was also really frustrating to me.
So, I met them once in person
after about a year and a
half of not speaking to them.
Because they were like, "I'm in London",
I lived in London.
They were like, "Wanna hang out?"
And I was like, "Fine, we'll
meet up for afternoon tea
as you do.
- Afternoon tea.
- And then, like,
these Americans.
Filthy Americans, I'm joking.
So they turned up,
and there was like two other people there,
who looked very, very young.
- [Joey] Okay.
- Like, I asked one of
them, "How old are you?"
Cause they, it was really weird as well,
cause they were like attached to them.
- Right.
- And I thought,
"That's really weird."
But they wouldn't-
They would take it in turns
holding onto the person.
- [Joey And Garnt] Right.
- I thought, "Wow, that's really suss"
And I just thought, "Americans
do American things".
(Garnt laughs)
- Because as a British person, right,
I don't understand things that
Americans do that are weird
or fucked up.
Cause Americans are just quirky, right.
Some Americans just do their own thing.
- We all have our own con stories
about people doing weird things-
- That one weird American.
(group laughs)
- Yeah.
- I remember asking one of these kids,
"How old are you?"
And they were like, "18."
And I remember thinking,
"You don't look 18,
you look like 16."
And I was like, "Is your parent
okay with you coming here alone?"
And they were like, "It's okay."
And I was like, "All right, whatever."
And it was really weird, I went home,
I never spoke to them again
because I was really creeped out.
I left early cause I made an excuse
that I had to go.
- Yeah.
- Cause it was just weird.
- Cause there was just like
kids basically with him.
I didn't sign up for this,
I thought we were going to have
an awkward conversation
for like two hours, alone.
And then I'd go home.
(Joey And Garnt laugh)
I thought that was what it was.
And then two, three months later,
it must have been.
No, no, no, it was like 8 months later.
I get a DM on Discord,
"Hey, you should see this."
And it was a link to a local police report
and I thought, "What the fuck."
- [Joey] Right.
- So I click on it,
and it's like two counts of molestation
and one count of felony molestation.
- [Joey] Aww.
- Oh no, aggravated molestation.
Which I think is under 14 years old.
- [Joey] Yeah
- Bruh.
- Now, yeah, and they were
person who identified as a male
but they were born female.
So I think that's why a lot of people
just never thought that
they would do something.
- [Joey] Yeah
- Right.
- But yeah, I can't remember
what happened with them.
I don't wanna keep up with it,
like I don't care,
it's a mess.
- And I guess your hunch was correct
in that sense.
- Yeah, yeah
- And it's one of those things
where it's like fuck man, I
collabed with this person a lot.
I think the moment I found out
that they were being
charged with all this stuff,
you know, even if,
you are innocent until
proven guilty, right.
- Yeah.
- But, it just didn't sit right with me,
leaving that stuff up.
Even if there's a chance,
I don't wanna leave it up.
So I took all the videos down
which is like 40 or 50.
If you go to my Social Blade,
you'll see like views, views,
minus 9 million views,
views, views, views.
I took them down.
I still get comments being
like, "Where are the videos?"
And I'm like I don't want to
break this bubble, you know.
- I mean, I guess you just did.
- I guess I did now,
and it was just, oh god, it was terrible.
And you think back,
and you're like "Fuck, why?
Why did you have to do that?
What's wrong with you?"
And I felt really guilty for ages
cause I was like, "Fuck, did I help them?
Did I facilitate this by giving
them more of a platform?"
- [Joey] Yeah.
- It was just fucked up.
Everyone I knew who was close to him
also was really weird.
And it was just like,
it was a thing of like
just record this one thing
and then please leave me
alone, all the time before.
- Yeah
- Because they were so weird
and I should have listened to my gut.
I don't know why I did, I regret.
- I mean, you always have
that first kind of experience
where meeting people on the Internet
might not be the best idea sometimes,
or some people are just
really weird on the Internet-
- Some people are, some people are.
- And you don't always get that
until you actually hang out in real life,
when it's not like in a Discord call.
- I mean, my early YouTube
career was definitely that.
Because when I was still
doing gaming stuff,
naturally I would also bond together
with other gaming YouTubers
who were also trying to grow.
So, I think this is back when
I had less than 10,000 subs.
I had this huge group of
friends I used to collab with.
And a lot of them I never met in real life
until much, much later.
And when you do,
you really get, as you said,
you finally get a sense of
who this person actually is.
And unfortunately sometimes,
they're completely different.
- [Garnt And Connor] Yeah, yeah.
- It's scary how much some
people can just fake that shit.
- [Connor] Yeah
- Until they think they can
get away with it, right.
- It's really made me listen to my gut
when I have a bad feeling about someone.
- Yeah.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- And now I don't even try,
I don't humor them, I'm just like-
- No, cause like right now,
it's made, like, my
experiences have made me
like a lot more careful when
I meet people in real life.
Because you just have to be.
I wanna be, you know,
when you started out,
you tried to be friendly to everyone.
And I wanna be friendly to everyone-
- Yeah
- Cause I want give everyone
the benefit of the doubt.
But when there is just
this many people that,
you just gotta be careful sometimes.
And you gotta have that barrier up.
- Also, over experience, I
feel like you get a much more
of a keener eye on stuff like that.
Like you know if someone's doing something
for like suss reasons, you know.
- It just makes me sad
the sheer amount of people
who do fucked up shit like this.
- Yeah
- And it's just like
I don't understand it
cause my head is not even
remotely wired like that.
To me it's so foreign that
people could do this shit
and it's so confusing that so
many people do shit like this.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And it's like, "Why?
Why the fuck do you?-
- [Joey] Because the Internet-
- Don't fuck kids.
How hard is that?
(Garnt laughs)
How hard is it to not fuck kids?
I don't understand.
- [Joey] I know, I know.
- Um, excuse me, are you telling me-
(group laughs)
- It's just the thing right,
I say that and then someone-
- How do you argue about that?
How do you argue about that?
It's not even an argument.
- It's just like I don't-
- Also side note, if I ever
do meet you in real life
and you're like an online personality
that I might not know,
please introduce yourself
as your Internet handle.
I've had so many times when-
- Oh my god.
(Joey laughs)
- You're like, someone
introduces them to you,
and they're like, "Oh yeah, I'm Matt"
or something
and it's just like, okay.
Do I-
- Fans do that too,
they're like, "Do you remember me?"
And I'm like, "Who?"
And they're like, "X
girl with this avatar"
And I open up their profile
and they've changed it.
And I'm like, wait, how the
fuck was I supposed to know
who you are, if you don't
even show your face.
What do you want me-
- Especially,
especially people who
don't show their face.
- Yeah, what the fuck.
- And like-
- "I'm Jacob", it's like I know 70 Jacobs,
which one of the 70 are you?
- I know right, so.
- Should I go back on topic to the-
- Yeah, no like introduce
yourself by your Internet handle.
Just-
- It's awkward.
- I feel like, I get it.
Because it's weird, like
I feel weird being like,
"Yeah, hi I'm Gigguk."
You know what I mean?
I get it.
- I just say, "Hi, I'm
Connor, CDawg online."
- Yeah, yeah.
Just like introduce
yourself with that in mind.
So we know, because we don't.
Nowadays, people know each
other by their Internet handles,
a lot of the times.
- More people know you for
Gigguk than Garnt, probably.
- Yeah.
- That's cause,
that's how it is.
- I mean, that's fine by me
because like, Gigguk,
I don't know how you guys got your names
but I mean.
(Garnt laughs)
I don't know the story with The Anime Man.
I don't know how the fuck
you thought of that name.
- It's all that SEO, bro.
That's all it is, baby.
- To get his views in the Recommended.
- But like, for me, Gigguk
has always just been,
it was a family nickname
that my Dad thought up when I was born.
So like, I'm just used to it.
So if someone calls me Gig or Garnt,
like my family to this
day still call me Gig,
so like I'm used to hearing that.
I'm completely comfortable with people
just calling me Gigguk or Garnt.
- If my parents called me Anime Man,
I would think I was like
disowned or something.
- If you call me The Anime
Zone, on the other hand,
then now we got a problem.
Now we got a fucking problem.
(group laughs)
- I do that sometimes
just to fuck with Garnt.
- We do it, we do it.
We like to joke around on this podcast.
- Yeah, yeah.
(Joey laughs)
Yeah, that's the one thing I guess I-
It's really weird right
because I've never been used
to introducing myself as like,
"Hi, I'm The Anime Man."
Because, before all of this,
it was just so natural for me,
and I'm sure it is with a lot of people,
to just be like, "Hi I'm Joey."
Because I just want you to
get to know me as a person.
But, it's weird now how, it's
gotten to that point where
if you just say, "Hi I'm Joey.",
some people will just be like-
- Who the fuck's that?
- Do I, do I know you?
- Which Joey are you?
- How many subs do you have?
(group laughs)
- Are you even verified bro?
If not, don't talk to me.
Yeah, it's scary, numbers
on the Internet, man.
Scary shit.
It really scarily changes the perception
of how you see someone.
Even if you don't mean it that way.
- I think we touched on
that roughly in episode 1-
- Yeah.
- How we met each other and
how numbers played a factor.
- Yeah.
- Going back to what I was saying earlier
with the, how I always felt
like I was on the outskirts
of the community,
I think that experience very
much solidified to me like,
"I'm okay with not making friends"
- [Joey] Oh yeah, yeah.
- I'm gonna keep to myself,
but yeah, obviously I have you guys.
- I mean I very quickly
came to the realization
that again, you can't please everybody.
- Oh, no, no.
- So it's just best to like find that
however many group of people
that you know are cool
from here til now.
And just stick around with them.
- One thing I always felt weird
about the Anime YouTube
community specifically,
and this was very much as
an outsider looking in,
I mean I was in the community, right,
like I made content.
- Yeah.
- But I never participated in anything
and I didn't make the videos
they would typically consider anime-
- [Joey] Yeah right, right.
- Yeah.
- No other community does this,
where they try and like
rank who's the best
in their mind with content,
which I find really odd.
You never see the meme
channels being like,
"Here's the tier list of
the best meme channels."
You know what I mean?
(Joey And Garnt laugh)
You never get like, "Oh yeah,
no, Dolan Duck is better than-
- Yeah, yeah.
- You know what I mean?
No one gives a fuck.
Everyone is just-
- Yeah, no one gives a shit.
- Everyone's just like, "I like Grande."
No one does this weird thing,
but for some reason in
the anime community,
they are obsessed with
like ranking each other.
And seeing who has the best content.
- I only just noticed it's
only the Ani-Tube community.
- No other community does this
and it's so weird.
- Does the gaming community do this?
- No.
- No one does tier.
And it's weird how like,
on the outside looking in,
"Wow, they really just normalized
this amongst themselves.
They really just love
stroking each others egos."
And it's weird cause no other
content, no other community
does really does this where they like,
all they do is complement each other.
They're like, "Damn,
that was a good video."
It's like that business
meme, you know where like-
(Garnt laughs)
- Like, yes we did business.
- Very good business.
- Great business.
Great videos.
- Business executed.
- It's weird.
And as someone who didn't
do the type of content,
that anime content that they considered-
- You weren't 'officially recognized'.
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- As somebody, I'm sure
some of you are like,
know nothing about the
anime community, right.
So I'll break it down real quick to you,
how the anime community
works as an outsider.
And you can tell me if my
understanding is wrong.
- Okay.
- So I made anime content that
was very entertainment based.
I would take characters and
do weird stuff with them,
like prank calls.
- Yeah.
- The anime community
has two types of videos
that they consider anime content.
If you see a tier list
likely anything else
that is not this will be ranked lower.
And that's reviews or analytical videos.
- Yeah.
- And what I mean by that is obviously
reviews of shows if you review shows-
- Or episodes.
- Or episodes, or manga,
you know whatever.
Analytical videos, where you do that shit
that you did in English class
where you break down why
the curtains are blue-
- You basically write an essay about-
- Yeah.
- You write a 20 minute video on
why Deku fists in the appropriate
way that he does, right.
(Garnt And Joey laugh)
It's how Deku mastered
his fisting technique.
20 minute video, red circles, right.
It's that type of content
where they like, or the
logic of Haruhi Suzumiya.
It'll have a title like that, right.
- Basically, you gotta
talk about a specific show
or you gotta talk about
anime shows in general.
- And it's a really strange obsession
where amongst themselves,
all these small YouTubers,
I'd say between
10-100k.
They're obsessed with doing these videos
and who can do the best of
these videos and ranking.
- Yeah
- And it's so odd looking
from the outside in,
it's just like, weird
watching them fight over this.
And it's like, what's happening?
This has gone beyond
criticizing each other's work.
To a point of like extremes, I think.
- Yeah.
- It's gotten really strange.
- It's just become a giant circle-
- And they don't really-
Yeah, it's a giant circlejerk.
- It's a circlejerk, right.
- And they don't really recognize
any other type of content,
and I'm okay with that cause-
What I think it comes down to most
is that most people who make videos,
I'd say most YouTubers,
make it to serve the audience
or to make content for the audience.
These YouTubers in the anime community
make content for each other.
- Yeah.
- And to be appraised by each other
and have their content, you know.
If Gigguk gives me the A+ on my video,
that's all I've ever wanted, right.
- I've passed this semester.
(Joey laughs)
- Exactly, cause obviously
I want to be validated
by my peer, who doesn't right?
But that's not the only thing I wanted
when I started making content.
- No.
- For these Ani-Tubers, it's
the be-all-end-all, right.
- That's, I could be wrong,
and I'm sure a lot of them would disagree.
But from the outside looking
in that's what it seems like.
- I actually totally agree with you.
I don't think it's just the anime YouTube
I've seen this specifically.
Or at least the Ani-Tube community.
I remember I had a very similar experience
when I first started dipping my toes
into the abridging community.
Now, this was all the way back in the day
where abridging was like the shit.
- Yeah.
- Everyone wanted to be
like TeamFourStar.
And everyone was making
their own abridged content.
And everyone had, like, a
lot of different approaches.
And a lot of them were shit, right.
(Connor And Joey laugh)
I-
- They all tried and they failed.
- You can say that
though, you can say that.
- But a lot of them were shit-
- They were, they were.
- Because abridging is hard, it's hard.
I've done abridging,
I can wholeheartedly
say it is fucking hard.
But what happened is this community formed
and there was like these
forums that popped up.
And what happened was people
would just start to criticize
each other's work, each
other's writing on comedy.
- Yeah.
- Right, and-
- Like they were all experts.
- No, no, no.
Cause it did become kind of a circlejerk,
where people were, in the end,
making content to appeal to each other.
You know what I mean?
People were literally on these forums
reviewing comedy writing and abridging.
And not to say like-
(Connor laughs)
- That sounds so pathetic.
- Not to say that comedy, there
isn't a size around comedy.
Or like there isn't like a framework
that you can work off of.
But what that did,
it just made a lot of
abridging so fucking stale.
And so fucking same-y.
- Yeah cause everyone's
trying to please each other,
so everyone's trying
to write the same shit.
- Yeah, yeah.
- But then I also feel like what happened
is that when a big channel,
say TeamFourStar right.
If they give positive praise to someone
who is up and coming, you know,
maybe they will think,
"Oh, they were nice to me
so I'll praise their writing."
And then, it's just this giant circlejerk
of like the people who
want to be respected
and the new guys who want to be respected.
They all just pass around the
compliments to each other.
- Yeah.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Cause they're like,
"This is what we need,
we need this respect from each other."
- Yeah exactly.
- And, I see the exact same thing
with a lot of smaller Ani-Tubers now,
where they try,
they try to make content
to appeal
to each other-
- Other YouTubers.
- Other Youtubers,
which is why whenever you see,
whenever I see an Ani-Tuber
that just does something
totally different.
You can tell, right, when an Ani-Tuber
makes a video
that is completely, and they
don't watch other Ani-Tubers-
- You can tell straight away.
- Cause they always make
a name for themselves.
I remember the first time it happened
was with Demolition D.
Like, you can tell,
he had a completely new style
that no other Ani-Tuber
had before.
And I remember like, I remember watching
one of his videos early on.
I remember thinking, "He's
gonna fucking blow up."
- Yeah.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- And that's exactly what happened
and now he's quit now.
He's like that urban legend
for us Ani-Tubers, right.
But he's like one of the most
respected content creators
in Ani-Tube.
But like I remember John,
Super Eyepatch Wolf,
when he first came out,
I knew he didn't watch
any other Ani-Tubers-
- Oh, you can tell, you can tell.
- He fucking blew up as well.
I'm trying to think if
there's anyone recently.
Oh, I've got one.
I've never talked about him before,
there's this guy called Scamboli Reviews.
- [Joey] Okay
- You've mentioned him before.
- He's like very, I can tell
he's very new to the scene.
And I've seen a lot of
opinions about him online
within the Ani-Tube community,
and a lot of it is very negative.
Just because the way he phrases it,
phrases things,
and the way he goes about his videos
is way more like different
and some would say
brash and harsh, maybe arrogant.
But from like myself, a
content creator's perspective,
comparing his content to a lot of things
the other Ani-Tubers are doing.
I could say he definitely has
a more distinct personality.
And he definitely stands out,
even if I don't agree
with all of his content
or the way he approaches the content.
I can see that he approaches
it, he just feels-
- Got an angle right?
- He just feels different from the rest,
even though he's technically
doing analytical content.
And he's like grown a lot faster
in a short period of time.
And I feel like we talked about this,
making content to appease other YouTubers,
and sometimes you can
definitely tell that.
- Oh yeah, I mean,
I think the reason why someone
like John, Super Eyepatch
Wolf, and yourself
are able to get plus a million views
on a video talking about
a very specific thing
that maybe people aren't interested in.
Is because I think priority
is make the video good.
Don't, it's not about
trying to appease someone
or trying to impress another YouTube.
Because I feel like when you do that,
you're just going to iterate
on someone else's idea
that probably wasn't
already good to begin with.
But you think it's good
cause in your mind,
that's what you've been
told by the community
is the golden standard.
- Yeah, yeah.
- When it should be, just
make the good content.
- Just make content.
Because I remember going
back to the abridged thing.
The meta-game was try to make something
better than TeamFourStar.
It was, it was like I'm going
to make an abridged series
and I'm going to try and
make this more respected
in this own circle than
what the big guys are doing.
And I'm pretty like TeamFourStar,
they didn't really give a shit.
- No, no.
- You know what I mean?
They were innovating with DBZ Abridged
and HellSing Abridged.
And they were just doing their own stuff,
and they were doing stuff
cause they thought it was good, you know.
As someone who has been on
YouTube for a very long time,
you can definitely feel when
someone is making content
with a completely unique angle.
- Oh yeah.
- You get a lot of the same reactions
because a lot of, sometimes
people come up very fast
and people are like, "Why
is he coming up very fast?"
- A lot of the small YouTubers
get very bitter about that.
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
- And they're very harsh about it.
But then when I can look at the content,
or any of us,
and we can see exactly why it succeeded.
We can break that apart.
And like, talking about TeamFourStar,
I remember, I'm a voice
actor, that's what I do a lot.
I've voiced a ton of abridges.
And the only time I've been laughing
while I was recording
was during the HellSing
Abridged that I did.
And I remember I couldn't
get the lines done
because I was laughing too much.
And I never have that problem
with any other abridge, right.
- Taka's such an amazing writer.
- It was such a good abridge for the time,
it was incredible.
It's because they didn't give a fuck
about trying to copy
or trying to get the
respect of someone else.
Because they would just
focused on making the product.
- They just made shit that
they thought was funny.
- [Connor] Yeah, yeah.
- You know, that's what it is.
- And it's just like,
not everyone who just
makes stuff for themselves
makes good stuff, you know what I mean?
- Yeah, yeah.
- That's not like, we're not trying to say
you can't improve yourself
by looking at other people.
- Respect doesn't pay your bills.
(Garnt And Joey laugh)
- That's a good way to say it.
- Respect doesn't pay your bills, right.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
- At the end of the day, you know.
If typically, with how the
YouTube algorithm works,
like we all love to shit on it.
But at the end of the day,
if you make something
that people are watching,
YouTube will be like
let's recommend it more.
If people are watching your videos,
you will get viewed.
That's just how it works,
it sucks that it's like that.
Yes, there are occasions
where YouTube does it's little
fuckery and drops the ball
- Yeah.
- But that doesn't happen
to every one of your videos.
- Yeah.
- And there are YouTubers
out there, you've seen a bunch of them
who are complaining like,
"Oh, I've been shadow banned."
No, your videos are garbage.
(Garnt laughs)
It's-
- That's the harsh truth, isn't it?
- It's just the truth, right?
- Your videos are bad
and I can say that
because my videos were bad at one point.
- It's not just that,
because I've seen many really
fucking great YouTubers,
anime YouTubers as well,
who do fucking amazing content,
no idea how to market their stuff.
No idea,
no idea
how to like, title and
thumbnail their videos.
- It's a big-
- There are like some Ani-Tubers
where I'm like this is
a fucking great video
but I don't know what half these words
in your title mean, right?
How is anyone going to
click on this video?
- It's like, "Am I
clicking on an anime video
or am I clicking on a scientific study?"
- [Connor] Yeah, yeah.
- Cause like some of these
words, I'm just like,
"Wow, I didn't know these
existed in the English language
and could be related to
anime in such a way."
- And it does suck in a way
that you have to play to the YouTube meta
of just how to title
and thumbnail a video.
Because, you know, I'm sure
we've titled and thumbnailed-
- We don't wanna click bait,
we're forced to click bait.
- No, no, cause you do.
And there's different
levels of click bait,
but like, sometimes I'm like,
"You know what? It hurts me
that I have to title it this way but."
- It's the only way.
- It's the only way people-
- No one's gonna watch it otherwise.
- Yeah, exactly.
And that's just part of being
a YouTuber, unfortunately.
- Hate the game, not the player.
- Okay like, for example,
I did an Arch Knight sponsorship recently.
Love the game right,
but I titled the video
"I Spent $800 On An Anime
Mobile Game", right.
It's not an anime, it's anime styled.
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah.
- It's a more accurate title,
would be something like,
"How To Play-
- I love Arch Knights
- Yeah, like,
that would be way more accurate
but people aren't gonna click on that.
Because they don't know
what Arch Knights is.
If I give them a generic enough title
that's interesting enough,
they'll click on it.
And it's just trying to
strike that balance, right.
Between not lying to the audience
but also being honest.
- [Joey] Right, right.
- I had the exact same problem
with my Gacha game video.
Cause I put so much fucking work
into this Gacha game video
that I'm like, a lot of people do not know
what the fuck Gacha games even
are, you know what I mean?
How do I, how do I get
someone who has no idea
about Gacha games to give
this video a chance, you know?
- Yeah.
- Cause I think it's a
pretty good introduction
to the world of Gacha
and everything, you know.
Go watch it, I put a lot
of time and effort into it.
(Joey laughs)
- Links down below.
- I'm gonna shout myself out.
(Joey laughs)
I put like a month of
work into that video.
- This episode is sponsored by Gigguk.
- But like, it was just really hard for me
to figure out how to properly market
this to an audience.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- And that's part of the challenge
of being a YouTuber.
Like, how long do you spend
on your titles and thumbnails?
Out of curiosity.
- Sometimes you just know
and sometimes you sit there
for 2 hours and get confused.
- I mean, nowadays, when
I think of a video idea,
the first thing I think of,
even before I start writing it a script
or getting the general idea down,
is what's the title and thumbnail.
- Yeah, I think I do that
like 80% of the time.
- Yeah because if no matter what,
I can't think of a good enough
title or thumbnail for it.
I usually don't even
bother doing the video.
Until I can think of like,
okay with this title,
people click on it.
And then I can start working on it.
And try and base my
content around that title
as much as I can,
so that it's not like, "Aw,
this is completely click bait.
This has nothing to do with
the content of the video"
Which is hard and like annoying
because like sometimes I
have to sacrifice content
for the sake of the title.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- Which is the worst thing you can do.
- Going back to the point I made earlier
where I was mentioning
making shit content,
I've been guilty of making shit content.
- I think we all have.
- When I was only making
Black Butler videos,
I remember I couldn't watch my own videos.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Is that bad?
- No.
- Have you been there?
- I've always said to people,
if you can't watch your old stuff,
then that's good cause that means
you're not only getting-
- More better.
- Harsher on your content,
but now you know how to
improve your content.
Just don't make that shit.
- Do you ever feel like,
right after you made it,
you're like, "This is bad."
But I'm gonna upload it anyway?
Cause I feel like you wouldn't do that.
- Oh, I don't get to that stage.
- I do have like a bar of quality,
where I have, I've literally,
there's been one video recently
where it's been, I've
recorded it, I've scripted it,
I've recorded it, edited it
and no matter I try to jig around with it-
- It just didn't work.
- It just didn't work,
and I just scraped it.
And that was like a good
two weeks of work, as well.
- Fuck.
- It hurt, but for me, if I'm not like,
I don't always have to be like,
"This is the best shit ever"
- Yeah, yeah.
- This like 10/10 banger,
every fucking time.
- Just good enough.
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah.
- Sometimes it's like,
"Okay, this is good enough."
And even that hurts me
to release sometimes.
Just like good enough.
But like question to you guys,
have there been any videos
that you've ever regretted?
Or like you can't-
- My first early part
of YouTube.
- Yeah.
- My first four years.
- I, okay I'm gonna say this
and I know it's not true,
looking back I feel like I hated it
but I know I didn't, right.
I enjoyed what I used to make.
But it was never what I wanted to make.
I made one or two things
that I did want to make.
And then I made more of that
until I got stuck making
only Black Butler stuff.
- [Joey] Right.
- And that was a nightmare to get out of
because like anything I made
that wasn't Black Butler,
no one watched it.
No one.
(Garnt laughs)
And I remember, I
remember I moved to London
and I was making like 1500
pounds a month, right.
- Yeah.
- Which in London, this
is before tax, before tax.
- Scraping by, just scraping by.
- I was basically scraping by
and I remember and for
some reason I was adamant.
I'm like, "I'm not fucking
making these Black Butler videos
all the-
I was still making them
but I'm not making them
all the fucking time.
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And all of them bombed,
like straight up, all of them bombed.
I was getting like 1/3 the
views I was normally getting.
I was like, "I'm gonna go homeless.
I'm gonna have to go back to my parents
and be like I fucked up."
But, you know, I was persistent.
I was like, "No, I'm not.
I'm gonna make this fucking work.
They're funny, I think they're
better than my old stuff."
And eventually it did take off.
But I remember, like,
the reason
why I realized I had to change
was cause someone told
me, "Oh, that's weird
that you can't watch your own videos."
Like at all, like not even reviewing it.
I couldn't review it, I
had to get someone else
to review for me.
- Oh really.
- Cause it was like, I would
cringe too much watching them.
(Joey laughs)
Cause I didn't like it.
- Yeah, I get exactly the
same feeling sometimes.
- But like now, when I make a good video,
I'm like, "I fucking love this part."
(Joey And Garnt laugh)
- That guy's hilarious.
- You watch it like two or
three times before it goes live,
it's just like, yeah,
this is gonna be a banger.
I'm like, "Here comes the
joke, ah yeah, I killed a joke,
I killed that joke.",
you know what I mean?
I'm so happy with what
I'm making right now.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- It feels like a whole,
like I've been unchained
you know what I mean?
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah.
- But it's hard because
I see a lot of YouTubers
and I remember cause I used to help out
with a lot with comic doubles.
Who would dub like Undertale comics.
Remember that, when that was a thing.
- Oh yeah, of course.
Homestuck comics.
- All of these people
who would dub comics,
it was so easy to get hundreds
of thousands of views, right.
Cause these had huge fandoms.
They would get to like 200k subs,
they'd wanna start branching out.
Boom.
None of the videos would get views,
and I was like trying to help them.
But a lot of people when
they get one or two videos
that do bad or perform poorly,
they're immediately put off.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- They won't try anything else.
They're just like it just doesn't do well,
it doesn't do well.
And they don't want to figure
out how to make it work.
Cause it's basically
like starting from zero,
with a little bit of an advantage.
But you basically have to get
rid of all your old audience
and get a new one.
- It's probably less
discouraging starting from zero
because at least from zero-
- You've got nothing to
lose, you know what I mean.
- Which is why my number one
piece of advice from the get-go
is make what you want,
don't make what gets views.
Cause I did that and I fucked myself over.
I'm lucky
because I feel like I'm
1 out of 100, right,
who managed to change his content.
- Yeah, you got very, very lucky.
- And get away from it.
Cause I was persistent.
I did not stop.
- I was kind of in a similar situation-
- Right, yeah, yeah.
- Not to the extent of
you with Black Butler,
but I was kind of there
when I did a lot of
Corpse Party stuff.
- Right, I remember that, I remember that.
- I originally blew up
playing Corpse Party 2?
Which was like the new Corpse Party game
that just come out.
But it was only in Japanese.
The first let's play, that
was like the first let's play
I ever did, I remember.
It was like my eighth video or something.
- [Connor] Oh my god.
- [Garnt] Right, right.
- And it just immediately blew up because-
I didn't know how dedicated
the Corpse Party fan base
was back then,
and it got to the point
where I would do Corpse Party 2,
it would just get insane amount of views.
Like way, way more than
any of my anime content.
- [Connor] Right.
- And then I found a Corpse
Party spinoff visual novel
which no one also did cause
it was only in Japanese.
I did like 30 episodes of that.
All the episodes fucking killed it.
- [Garnt And Connor] Yeah.
- And it got to the point
where any other video I
did during that period,
I'd say like over 90% of the comments
were filled with Corpse Party Rpers.
- Yeah
- Oh really?
- Just like replying to
each other's comments
as Corpse Party characters.
(Garnt laughs)
And I looked at that
and I was like,
"Okay, I shouldn't get
stuck in this rabbit hole.
This is bad."
- I gotta get out of here.
- I gotta get out of here, dude.
I gotta get the fuck out.
(Connor laughs)
- And one of the things
that I tell other YouTubers
who are like at 10-50,000,
who are stuck in a content
where they can't get out of it.
Where it's the only content
that gets views by doing
the certain amount of thing
over and over again like
a pet almost, right?
- Yeah.
- Like do the thing you did
but differently slightly.
- [Joey And Garnt] Yeah.
- I always tell them like,
think of it this way,
maybe if you changed
your videos up entirely,
the 50,000 subscribers
that you're so desperately
clinging onto right now
could be a million, right?
Like, don't worry about
the subscribers you have,
cause most of them only care
about that one thing, right.
And if you want to change,
you don't need them.
- Subscribers change all the time,
they always recycle.
- Subscribers don't really mean much
in terms of view counts nowadays
because it's all about Recommended.
- I mean, look at this channel.
- Yeah no, exactly.
We're at like 300k breaking
over 500k every episode.
I'm like how is that happening?
- And it's like YouTube
used to be able to show you
how many people unsub from your channel,
but they removed it.
But it used to show you at like 600k,
it was like plus 600,000
subscribers minus 80,000.
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah.
- You will like siphon
out people, in a good way.
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah.
- Like, you'll lose the
audience that you don't want.
And that's okay.
But it's hard to teach people that.
Because like YouTube's hard.
- Because all they see
is that minus 80,000
and they're like, "I could be at 680,000",
instead of 600,000 but.
- Cause like for me,
part of the reason I feel
like I've been able to
be on this platform for so long,
is that I always like
try to change my content.
It's always like a conscious
effort at this point.
- Same, same.
- Like if I look at my content
last year, and I'm making
the exact same content,
like I don't feel like you need to do
a big fucking change straight away.
But if you gradually
change over the years,
it will be totally fucking different.
Because like, if you look at
my content from 5 years ago,
totally different from what I do now.
- Yeah.
- The way you implement that
is you do things a little bit at a time.
How I see it is, if I'm doing
exactly the same content
as I'm doing last year,
to me, I've failed.
And I've personally failed myself.
I remember last year, it was probably
like my best overall year,
in terms of views on my channel.
And I was actually like,
I was really unhappy with my channel.
Because this is exactly the
same stuff I've been making
last year for an entire year.
And it hurt me, it like hurt me.
And I didn't know what
I wanted to do next.
So it took me, like, a little
bit longer to figure out.
Okay, I want to try something different
in this way and that way.
But it's part of the secret
of being able to survive
on YouTube for so long.
- You're evolving.
- Oh yeah.
- It's like you constantly
have to be looking
for that evolution.
- Yeah well that's the
scariest thing, right.
There's nothing scarier than
YouTube viewers losing
interest in a YouTube channel
than the actual YouTuber losing interest
in their YouTube channel.
- Like I feel like you've
really upped your game
in the last year.
- Oh no, you have.
- I definitely have, I mean.
I think late 2019, 2019
for me was a weird year.
Because at the beginning of 2019,
I was kinda in the same boat
where I just kinda looked at my channel
and I thought, "This is the
same shit I've been doing
since I moved to Japan.
- [Garnt And Connor] Yeah.
- Just like a little bit better editing.
Yeah, I mean,
I think late 2019 was where I was like,
"You know what, I'm gonna kinda slow down
on the analytical stuff.
Like do way less scripted shit,
and kind of just do more fun,
entertainment based stuff.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- I don't have to
always be like the big brain boy of anime.
- Yeah, I feel like we all
rubbed off on each other almost.
- I think so
- Yeah, I think definitely
moving here and seeing how you guys work
has like given me like
a different perspective
about how content can be made.
And like different approaches.
Cause I feel like a lot of people
when they think about
making their content better,
they're like, okay, maybe
getting better equipment-
- There's definitely a factor of that.
- And there is a factor of that,
or sometimes like I gotta
make my writing better.
But sometimes it's just
what if you just try
approaching your content in
a completely different way.
- Yeah.
- And I mean,
going back to Ani-Tube
where everyone tries to make content
to appeal to each other.
What I see is content being
approached exactly the same way.
- Oh yeah.
- From like 5 different perspectives.
- And it's all the same,
it's just an iteration on each other.
Like, they don't do anything different.
- Which is why I find it
weird about the tier list
because I can definitely see
how you can find X content's better
but to me, it's like, you're
approaching it in the same way.
Someone might have better
editing or better writing,
or just better or more interesting ideas,
but it's still kind of in the same niche.
- It's the same shit.
- They can, they'll sit
here and talk about.
I remember, I don't know
which YouTuber it was,
but they like, "His clip
selection was poor".
And I'm like, who the fuck gives a shit
about his clip selection.
(Garnt laughs)
Like, who cares?
Who watches a video of an anime review
and thinks this clip selection
is rather disappointing.
You don't think that.
If the video is at a point
where you're nitpicking that much,
I feel like that-
- The content is stale at that point.
- Unless it's that egregious, right.
Where the clip selection
is that poor, right.
It shouldn't be a factor.
- Yeah.
- When you're talking about anime,
picking the right clips
doesn't fucking matter
it's what you're talking about.
- As long as the clips not in 240p,
no one gives a shit.
- I mean, which is why like,
I don't know like,
personally the thing that I
try to improve the most on
is how comfortable I am on camera.
I'm always trying to up it.
Like I wanna make it feel like
it's just like my best friend in the room.
Like how you doing?
- I've always been
trying to figure that out
for the past year or so,
even with scripted content.
How do I make scripted content
not look like scripted content?
Because a year ago, you could tell
if a video of mine was scripted.
It was very, very obvious.
- I never script anything.
- From the way I presented it
and the way I talked,
but now recently, I've slowly kind of,
I've put more effort into
remembering my scripts,
rather than reading a little bit of it
and then using my short
term goldfish brain memory
to be like, "Recite these
words in a natural way please."
(group laughs)
- Dude, I don't know how you,
I did a script recently for the first time
and I hated it so much.
- You get used to it,
I hated it at first too but.
- I just love being a crackhead,
just saying shit.
(Joey laughs)
Just saying shit and then being like,
we'll piece it together, we'll figure-
- I'm like completely opposite,
I need, I love making a script.
Like, I was that kid, it's weird
cause I was that kid who
was just sitting in school
and I would just be sitting in silence
and I would just laugh at myself.
I would just be like (chuckles)
- Bruh.
- Better run, better run.
- People thought I was like fucking crazy.
- Yeah I would, I would.
- But like, it was because
I had all these funny ideas
and funny jokes that I couldn't-
- 13 year old Garnt: I'm a comical genius.
- Like I can-
- I'm a comical mastermind.
- There's no way I can
explain this funny thought
or funny joke I have in my head.
But as soon as I started
making YouTube videos,
I'm like that's a funny thing,
let's make this into a funny meme.
(Joey And Connor laugh)
And like I can actually visualize
all the crazy shit going on in my head.
I'm not crazy, I swear to god.
- Out of context, it
sounds slightly autistic.
(group laughs)
Just a little worrying.
- Sounds kinda rain man.
- Yeah, it is a little rain man-y.
- Good will hunting
(Joey laughs)
Comedy good will hunting.
(Garnt laughs)
My god.
- I don't know though,
cause I started with doing
absolutely zero scripts.
I would maybe jot down bullet points,
but I found myself, finding,
running into that situation
where I would just be like "Er, uh"
like way too much in between
while I was trying to
think up of something.
So, in the end, a video where
I'm trying to convince you
that you should think about
an anime in this certain way,
just ended up being this crackhead ramble
that just was not convincing whatsoever.
I was like, "Okay, I gotta
start organizing my shit."
- Sorry, I was just laughing.
I had the exact moment.
I was just laughing to myself
because I thought of a funny joke.
- God damn it, Anime Zone.
I am so-
- It just happened live on screen now.
I'm like god fucking damn it.
- Can we get a repeat of that?
At the moment you just see-
- Cause I was like,
I wasn't laughing at what you were saying,
I was just thinking of a funny joke.
- You're not funny, Joey.
- Fuck you.
- I'm sorry, I was derailing.
What were you talking about, Joey?
I was totally intently listening-
- I'm too in the moment,
I like don't find things funny
if I think about them too much.
- Yeah
- [Joey] Yeah.
- I don't know, sometimes
do you just have that joke
where you just like,
you just like, the more
you think about it,
the funnier it gets?
- Oh yeah, I have those jokes,
but it doesn't come to the point
where I'm just sitting there laughing.
- I don't think I'm funny
enough to make those jokes
where I'm like, "Damn, I'm funny.
Damn I'm good."
- I know, I don't think like,
sometimes I don't think I'm funny enough
to think on my feet a lot of the times.
- I'm the type-
- It's all I do.
Like, I can't.
If I think about a joke
too much, I hate it.
- I'm like that type of guy
who spends 30 minutes in the
shower slam dunking people.
(Joey laughs)
With like witty remarks that I didn't make
at the exact time.
- You don't know this bro
but I totally just fucking
destroyed you in my head.
(Joey And Garnt laugh)
- And then everyone clapped and cheered.
- It's like the end of Evangelion.
- How often do you need to do this, Garnt?
Where you need to think
about this in the shower.
Are you thinking about
your childhood traumas?
Like this guy-
- Like Sydney sometimes wonders
why I take 30-40 minutes
in the fucking shower,
on the fucking toilet,
and most of the time it's just me thinking
about different, that's
my most creative zone.
- It's like that meme where it's like
"He's probably thinking about other girls"
(Joey laughs)
- Meanwhile Garnt, "Hell yeah,
I destroyed you in my head."
(group laughs)
- Most of my video ideas come
when I'm shitting or in the shower.
I don't know why, it's
just my special place.
- It's the zen, man.
- It's the zen mo.
- I don't, I feel like I'm on my phone
when I'm shitting.
When I'm in the shower,
I'm also on my phone.
I have a little thing,
I watch YouTube videos.
All of my videos come right before,
I'm sure this is common,
but right before I go to bed.
Where I'm just about to drift off,
I'm just about to enter that REM state
and then all of a sudden,
I wake up
- Activate.
- I gotta write that down.
- Have you ever had a really funny dream
or a really great dream that you,
you wake up from that dream and you think,
"That will make an amazing video"
- Oh yeah.
- And then you make notes about it
and then you read it in the morning
and you're like what
the fuck was I saying.
- I've never experienced this
- Half of my videos are like
where I'm drifting off and I'm like
this would make a fucking hilarious video.
Half eyed, I write it on my phone,
I go to open it up
and I'm like what the
fuck, this is a shit idea.
- I've never experienced that in my life.
I've texted in my sleep
but I've never had that.
- I've written some mad gibberish.
I think it's a million dollar idea
and then I wake up and there was like
Evangelion, Indian service call.
I'm like what the fuck does this mean.
- Wait is that a real thing?
- Bye
- [Garnt And Connor] Bye.
(jazzy outro music plays)